hello everyone hello sorry guys um we were we were a bit
scuffed because we were trying to connect connect our collab
room well i didn't tell mint was i was accidentally doing a
joining collab room and not hosting collab room i was just
like why isn't it working i was like oh no i'm doing
everything correct it's the right password and then she's
like why don't you try it again like after like three times
and then i was like because like i'm she was like i'm
connecting but like it keeps kicking me off that i was like
you're right let me go check try it one more time and i
looked at it i was like oh i'm not hosting why should you
tell it i was like i thought it was fishy i thought it was
fishy the one time i was like are you sure it's connected
and then suddenly i can enjoy yeah and then i was like oh i
tried it again doesn't work and she's like oh it works down
like what did you i oh i guess i don't know what's going on
it's like it was down or something i was like yeah yeah yeah
it was down it was oh that's our streamer everybody my
streamer hashtag maoshi uh um it's donkey's fault i mean
that yeah show me your game oh yeah for yeah that too um
other than that i was telling uh men about heated robbery uh
because um right after yesterday's stream uh for hightail
snuffy was like you want to finish that episode of heated
robbery i was like yeah i guess i can eat dinner well like a
dinner and show you know and then and i was i was just it
was it was intense episode one and yeah we we also watched
the second episode too and it was how long are they like an
hour it was like i think so i think it's like an hour long
it's like an um hb like canadian hbo we have canadian hbo
called crave um and it's it's pretty gay i would say it's
it's it's pretty gay it's very gay because i was just like
whoa oh my god Yeah, people were telling me about it.
It's like based off of some real people or something.
It was like, it was based off a book.
So apparently, like, like there's a lot of closeted hockey
players.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because it's such a maddenly sport.
So like, a lot of them don't really want to come out.
Apparently, like, after the, after the show came out, a lot
of like, I think like one or two hockey players actually
came out of the closet because they were inspired by heated
rivalry and stuff.
you know like the amount of like a lot of people were
talking about it and so i was like oh it must be like you
know like the sex scenes i was like oh it must be like you
know pretty like not not like super intense no i've heard
i've heard that it's all raunchy and yeah it's yeah i was
like oh my fan fiction heart she's going back to pujo
everybody i was just like oh my god normally but it's on
camera.
It's...
The only thing I know, well, besides like that, it's super
sexy is like, I've seen like families watch it.
Like, yeah, because like I was thinking, oh yeah, wait, Game
of Thrones is sort of like Game of Thrones where like
everybody's watching it.
But then there's like some very intense scenes in Game of
Thrones.
It's basically like, like, okay, my favorite part, though,
is like, there's like, it's like every time they like swap
positions.
they do a fade to black like it's a you know like those like
point games on newgrounds and yeah you're very familiar with
that right like like i hear that'll explain it to you in a
way that you'll understand so every time they like change
positions they do a fade to black and there'll be a new
position i was like and then somebody was like wait this is
like there's like one two three four
It's looking crazy, I was just like, and then it's always
like three months later, and then like two weeks later,
there's so many like jump cuts to like be like, two years
later.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
Yeah, it got to load the new animation.
Oh, and then they're apparently, apparently it's so
influential that I just saw on Twitter that they, selected
to be the torchbearers for the winter Olympics yeah oh my
god yeah they're gonna be the torchbearer like there
obviously there's like lots of torchbearers but like the
actors also the Russian guy isn't even Russian he's fucking
Canadian yeah yeah I was like bro this Madden ain't even
Russian he's Canadian okay but it was actually it was a
really good Russian accent though it one thing i've heard
about the show is that because the guys like the actors are
so like they're they're blowing up like they're really
charming and like people like the actors themselves too yeah
but like other like i've heard that like other hollywood
actors are like upset about it because they're like we had
to like fight through hollywood and these guys come in and
they're on their random crave tv show and they get to people
it's a very respectable canadian hbo
it's all we have because hbo doesn't exist in canada so the
crave is all we have like yeah apparently they're like
really jealous right it's so rude like one of the one of the
guys was like was like a server at a restaurant like yeah
yeah yeah it's crazy also they're cheeked up they're very
cheeked up they have like it's crazy because i was like man
man these guys They have like really, they're like, their
chest is like, like mini boobs, I would say.
They're very puffy.
And then they have very...
Like a Pillsbury man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're like, damn.
And also their asses too.
I was like, damn, that's a bubble butt right there.
I mean, I wonder if they had to be like, you know, your
cheeks are going to be on screen a lot.
No, that's why.
We gotta enhance it.
We gotta do, like, special regiments for it.
That's why Snake's butt is big, because Kojima was like,
well, you're gonna be staring at it a lot.
Yeah, dude, did he scan that guy's butt when they did that?
Like, you know how, like, they scanned the lady's toes?
Well, I don't think they scanned anybody for him back in the
day.
Oh, they said they had to...
Oh, they had to hand-model it.
Yeah, they hand-model that.
Oh, so there's more love put...
There's more love put into it.
he was like more pixels more pixels it's not my vision in a
sense like 20 references like i need the butt to be like
this to the eye like little notes like red notes like like
notes for it too like he just he just sends a picture of his
hands like pretending to grip a butt and like to that size
to that more party yeah hand hand sculpted with care and
love like a sponge bob crabby patty like i know this is
really random i was just thinking about it oh so um so
there's this i just thought about it because we're talking
about games but apparently do you know like You didn't do
you hear about the there's a game coming on called marathon
and people were downloading the early access of it And when
they download early access of it destiny 2 gets installed on
your PC So they they they installed the early access game
and then and then they also installed destiny 2 It just
randomly shows up on your PC.
It's crazy is that like a malware?
Yeah He's like, don't know.
I got Destiny 2 a monkey.
You will play Destiny 2.
I feel like that's actually like what malware is.
The Destiny 2 malware.
Wait, that's true.
They actually...
That's crazy.
They created their own malware.
Oh, yeah.
It's like the YouTube album.
Oh, I remembered that.
the youtube album remember that when apple first came out
with like the apple music and then youtube albums were like
installed onto your phone and you can never delete it what
no i don't remember that it was like when the first iphone i
think it was when the first iphone came out and then itunes
was a thing like when itunes first came out and then they're
like um and then whenever you sync your phone to itunes like
you have a youtube album a youtube album yeah youtube album
and to and then they were like you can't delete it oh wait i
think i do remember hearing about that yeah yeah yeah and
then like like legally you cannot get rid of the album too
so you have to like crack the iphone to delete oh my god the
iphone too yeah and then like people were complaining they
pay to like be stuck on the phone
It's crazy.
Someone's like, it's still in my library.
I still own the copy of the album.
Anyway, today we're playing Metal Gear Solid Dugdub.
It could be the final part because Mint said the rate we're
going that we might be able to finish it today.
I feel like if you play as much as you did last time, you
can beat it today.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
I'm a crocodile now.
My camels goes crazy.
I also forgot all the controls, by the way.
It's been a while.
Maybe one more part, then, guys.
Okay.
Maybe.
Who's that over?
Oh, that's a bird.
Wait, can I?
Yeah.
How do I get my gun?
Oh, there you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, no.
I can't see that bird.
Yes, I can.
Wait, oh, there are people here, so they will hear you
shoot.
Okay, but how close are these people?
The torch, the torch.
Oh, you're right.
I whack it.
There can only be one bird.
oh wait what the bird won't know
oh oh what's that wait who was that oh there's a guy behind
you i see him i see him right there where the fuck do you
see him well he's he probably will walk over here touching
with me that's right attack oh shit oh wait what the fuck
the camel's working
There we go.
Oh, shit.
Wait, there's more?
Oh, yeah.
There's guys here.
Okay, well, he already called them, so I'll send the big
guns.
I can't believe you didn't even get the vulture.
Sending reinforcements.
It's okay.
I have an idea.
Where the fuck did that come from?
Oh, you're poisoned.
Oh.
I can't just say it's the universe.
We don't want, like, English, too.
Order!
Welcome, Doki's, to 8,008th Dokiverse Council Meeting.
Wait, what's happening?
I tapped or something else!
Oh, there he goes.
So...
I wasn't panicking at all, yeah, it's like...
Okay, let's restart oh look he's like off he's like on your
body like i was i swapped to my mouse and keyboard and then
i accident guys did i accidentally go to the dokey cap like
dokey council yeah it was like a ace attorney look at this
there's some items over there on your right all right all
right this time okay this time we're fine now let me grab
the proper guns um turn to turn around Oh, hey, there's some
items here.
Why did you tell me that sooner?
Because I want you to suffer.
Oh, okay.
I mean, that's why you're here.
I think I'm the one suffering here.
We're having a great time.
What are you talking about?
Oh, yeah, I should eat real quick.
Fuck.
How do I...
Oh, this way.
Okay, wait, no.
This thing.
Okay, there we go.
Now, all right.
Oh, is it rotten?
Oh, yes.
Yeah, see, because there's little flies.
on it.
Oh, is that what happens if I eat it?
Would it be fine?
You might get sick.
Yeah, you'll be fine.
It'll be fine.
It's like a 50-50, right?
Yeah.
This is rotten.
Oh, I have a stomach ache.
Yeah.
My tummy hurt.
You can throw these at people, though, and they will...
Oh, I've got food poisoning.
Oh, that's no good.
Oh.
Nope.
There you go.
Antidote.
Antidote?
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh.
No?
What?
Oh, it's demon oh for the stomach yeah yeah yeah my tummy
hurt yeah i'll throw up what was i gonna say um yeah i can't
remember whatever oh i see them now yeah okay i only see one
guy you can crouch right remember you you don't you don't is
there a suppressor on your suppressor is not on oh oh okay
give me a sec um Um, there we go.
Yeah, now I can use mouse and keyboard again.
Oh.
He didn't know.
He was like, who shot me there?
There's a guy up there.
Oh, geez.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
I have birds.
Oh, the bird is going to eat them.
The bird will eat them.
And then if you eat the bird, it's like a cannibal.
Oh, my God.
You're right.
Look, he's eating.
No!
Let him finish.
Wait, I got it.
Got our bird.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, they're coming.
They're coming.
It's capitalism time.
Did you see him running?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's fine.
No consequences.
Okay, while you do this, I'm going to go get some water real
quick.
All right, don't worry.
Watch this.
Oh, there's another bird.
Oh, they're very slowly heading over.
Little do they know.
They're going into a death trap right now.
Oh, they're so scared of me, guys.
I don't have bullets.
Oh, I do not have bullets.
Oh
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I just realized that I forgot about bullets.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
It's fine.
It's fine, guys.
Okay, watch this, though.
Watch this.
Yeah, just use CQC.
There we go.
See, it's not easy.
the hill and like lie down that's what i would do okay no
it's fine well you got it yeah see i got it now i'm gonna go
get water okay now now i go grab ammo this is my cqc all
right nourish that's ammo oh that's not ammo it's literally
cqc close combat no one said i can't use guns for close
combat oh shit oh shit who is that who could that be who
could that be oh shit okay wait where's my gun all right i'm
dual wielding it okay there you go see it's that easy i'm
dual wielding all right grab this do you have bullets oh
shit don't there you go all right do you have bullets god
damn it they're none of the bullets that i need all right
come on i trust things are going well oh my i'm not getting
any bullets okay it's okay everything is going well welcome
to this part of the game all right maybe i should i should
really get rid of all these bats no no you can throw them at
the people yeah but i can also grab grab like okay whatever
whatever no no it's fine watch this they're eating the
people it's so crazy oh fuck they're so fast what do you
mean fast he was right in front of you oh my god it was like
a speed of light
oh man did you get a license plate on that bird right there
Nice.
Oh, hey.
There we go.
Let him eat.
It's all right.
Yeah, more food.
Oh, yeah, I can.
I can.
How do I do this?
Oh, there we go.
I want to throw...
I don't throw this at people.
What do I need a book for?
Oh, that's bait.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, I got a vampire bat.
I can throw people.
It started getting, like, shivery.
Oh, there's a guy right there.
Okay, wait.
all right
what's that why don't you duck man thank you here we go oh
come on get the food is he not is he not gonna get the food
oh do I have to throw it at him is that what I have to do
wait I got this
here okay um okay wait wait i have one more chance he's
gonna get it he's gonna get it is he let him get it okay
sorry i'm chilling all right is he getting it he's not
getting it why aren't you hungry
oh my god give him get let him try again let him try again
okay you're just gonna
okay now kill him oh wait he's eating it oh wait no he's not
all right i could i still have the food it still worked as a
divergent yeah it still worked guys i would go before that
version succeeded all right god damn it's just all grenades
Where the fuck are my actual loot?
Yeah.
I think they give you more in this area.
Okay.
They definitely don't give you a lot of M19 stuff.
It's so bad.
Oopsie.
That was a little...
Those birds.
Wait, why is it not zoomed in?
Oh, there we go.
You have to switch the view, yeah.
Oh my god, controller aim is so fucking close.
There we go.
Yeah, well, yeah.
Yeah, controller aim ain't it.
I'm pretty sure there's a scorpion over here.
It's okay.
Watch this.
He's annoying.
Kill him.
Nope, maybe.
Okay.
No, you want to hurt that little guy.
Look at him.
Oh, he doesn't care about it, you guys.
Yeah, scorpion food.
I heard your tummy growling too, though.
Yeah, I'm hungry.
All right, now.
Oh, wait, I should eat the vulture.
And they've had, technically, it's cannibalism.
Legally distinct cannibalism.
Yeah, the best type of cannibalism.
Hey, that's good.
Because it's like...
More...
It's like, okay, so it's like, you know, you don't...
You know how pigs can eat anything?
Yeah.
So, like, how would you know your pig didn't eat a person?
You know?
You would never...
know you would never know exactly they're here to eat you
know how like like some murderers they like dispose the body
parts by like feeding it to pigs because they'll literally
eat anything so like really what if what if your pig was
owned by a murderer oh hey it's a crowba cobra a crowba yeah
yeah it could be the mafia pig farms exactly how would you
know if your pig isn't owned by Posing bodies.
He's really tearing into that guy.
So technically, we could all be legally distinct cannibals.
We don't know.
You could have eaten...
Like if I eat like a pork or then... Yeah.
Maybe it was... He ate a human.
Exactly.
He might have eaten a human finger.
You don't know that.
Finger!
Yeah.
Anti-aircraft.
We're already aircrafts.
Yeah.
Remember that helicopter we blew out?
Oh!
so so i don't have to deal with them yeah because we blew it
up you don't have to oh he's like right behind you oh oh
what the fuck is that oh shit am i getting shot at am i yes
that's not fair okay there we go
why did you think that you could just get on there and play
because i didn't see anybody they're around wow cqc him cqc
oh cqc oh cqc oh oh oh fuck okay give me a sec okay cqc oh i
don't have my okay there you go oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah light it light it light it okay okay um not you don't
light up you oh yeah yeah there you go there you go cqc yeah
thank you oh That's all right.
Friendly fire.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
Okay, that's it.
That's it.
Give me a sec.
I'll get the sniper on.
That's it.
Mouse and keyboard time.
There we go.
See, it's that easy.
Wait, is that a helicopter?
I think there's a grenade.
No.
There you go.
He doesn't need that foot.
Or the other foot.
Okay, it's fine.
Everything is okay.
is there anybody else see no wait you don't hear them
shooting is there anybody else but there's just rapid
gunfire in the background you know it could be like it could
be a very big rat oh my god this is my home now how did that
make the allure go back to it could just be a very big rat
you don't know that was the ointment oh ointment what would
ointment be oh it's ointment the ointment how is there more
people oh my god where are they coming from there's a whole
army look who's taxis whose taxes do they go to i don't know
if you let them if you let the alert and the evasion go down
oh okay it's back up i thought i was safe from my in my game
nah i would just you know I'll just stay here.
Just let them.
Yeah, I'll eat while they do all that.
Got some more white, rummed vultures.
Yum, yum.
I can go for seconds.
All right, there you go.
All right.
Oh, how did it go back up?
I ate a fucking food.
Oh, don't.
Do you think they'll...
They won't see him.
There's no way.
Yeah, do you think they'll...
Does he notice?
Oh, he's so stupid.
Oh.
Trouble comes back.
See?
Everything is fine.
Yeah.
I'm just a mountain crocodile.
You know, the famous mountain crocs in Russia.
How the fuck is there?
Did it go back up?
They said they lost sight of me.
no now you're in caution so before you were in alert phase
and then evasion and then yeah there's like different phases
okay i understand naruto wait do i have the pistol now i
have ammo for it oh i do so nice yeah yeah all right nice
now i can go back to silent
you know you can like crouch and walk too that helps oh
that's true
No.
No, that too.
Just being a little crocodile.
Just a little crocodile.
Trying to find his way in this big world.
You're going the wrong way.
Just a little crocodile trying to find his way.
Yeah, I'm here to guide you through the world.
Just trying to find my place in this big scary world.
Yeah.
scary world so scary all right and there's guys maybe up
here oh no i'm fine all right yeah i feel so so safe right
now there's a hole there too if you want to like crawl
through it oh what's there oh it really just leads you to
the other side but if you i like all right you know what
this will be a stealth run starting now starting starting
now okay wait all stuff started why is snakes so oily it's
so like when the enemy team grabs a hold of them he can slip
right through oh I see it's like a strat did you see the guy
to the your left oh and you're right oh okay wait there's a
guy to my left oh there is it maybe I saw the guy to the
right because the camera angles are your camera Our work is
just very erratic.
Okay.
You think I can shoot him from here?
Yeah, I think so.
Now just hit the back, the peak of his head right here.
Oh, well, he's wearing a helmet.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I have an idea.
If I use the sleep dart and I angle it all the way up here,
and then, oh, oh, oh, you waited it out.
Yay!
Oh, see, there was another guy.
I knew it.
How did that?
Because of the explosion.
Oh.
How did they?
How did they know?
I think you could go.
I don't think I'm sick.
This area is like pretty.
I'm not gonna lie.
This area is ass.
Like, there's so many guys.
And like I just hate this terrain.
Oh shit!
There we go.
I'll just...
Get in the hole.
My little safety hole.
Okay, we're gonna do a stealth round starting now.
Who are they...
Who are they even shooting at?
They don't even know they're stupid.
Oh my god.
He doesn't see me.
He doesn't see you.
Can't see me if he's dead.
Okay, starting now.
How did he see you?
Exactly!
How did he see me?
Oh my god, he's literally right there, right above me.
Oh yeah, he sees you.
Oh yeah, no, he definitely sees me.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I gotta be in...
Whoa!
But they're stupid, silly little guys.
They don't know where you go once you hide again.
They don't know.
Yeah, they don't know.
They're so silly.
yeah they're stupid i got oh my god i think you know wait i
think you know that wait oh whoa whoa whoa whoa my little
hole my little hole okay all right i'll just dig another
hole yeah yeah i'll stay here it's gonna be my new home for
like a little bit how do you stealth this actually there's
just people everywhere yeah
he's trying to he's trying to get me out of my hole but
little does he know it's my hole oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh no you have no suppressor anymore oh there's the here
comes the birds you it comes here it comes yeah you might
want to start tranking them because that one has a
suppressor on it yeah i think so too all right let's see
maybe i have another trick oh i don't all right this time we
got this wait can i sleep the the flying guys is that
possible yeah yeah you could sleep anybody or anything like
any animal like how do i the bird oh my god going out that
yeah Why is it, like, still in this view?
Because you're still in the hole.
It's not...
Oh.
Yeah, they die still, but...
Technically, I'm not a murderer for that.
Okay, you're in evasion.
Nice, nice.
Okay, nice.
Technically...
Oh.
What the fuck?
Oh, you don't let him see you.
There you go.
Nice, nice.
And then...
Yeah, and then just stab him.
to hit yeah yeah yeah yeah oh watch out blind oh my god you
could hold that guy up or you could um do that oh i forgot
this is easier oh yeah oh yeah this is easier to deal with
all right so i don't have to stab i just walk over them
there you know maybe you guys will take another stream what
do you mean it's a bird okay what's on the right side
nothing okay just keep going up all right you're not even in
the worst area you haven't met the guys with the
flamethrowers wait what there's a flame okay all right
starting now we're in new stealth mode
bum we have an idea
yeah they do have to be in the range you know there go they
don't know and then two of them know two of them know oh
okay watch this two world red they don't know um are you
guys
Sure.
Um, yeah?
They don't know.
Eat some bird.
I got eat.
I still have plenty of birds.
Hey, that's good.
Okay, wait, wait.
I can try this again.
I have, like, 20.
Boom.
What's wrong?
Oh.
You think that hit him?
No.
Please respond.
Oh.
Torch them Just run in and torch them That's okay There we
go I think they're dead Just go Go go go go Go go go Go go
go Go go go Oh wait can I torch them Can I torch them if
they're still alive Just try Torch Torch Torch Oh wait Oh!
RPG!
Don't get smash damaged.
Alright, now we stealth.
For real.
With RPG.
You'll never expect it.
Full stealth!
What is happening?
you doing i don't know i'm just trying to step oh what the
fuck you go into the right by the way yeah see now the
alert's going down i told you it just works non-lethal run
starts now all right back to back to reality all right back
to all right let's get rid of the ak and then all right oh
wow you're actually using it see it see it non-lethal
starting now unlethal all right keep going around this
building and and through there yeah oh wait but oh wait so
you can explore the other areas if you want actually
nobody's coming over anyway i killed everybody yeah right
now i think okay yeah wait who's that over there oh no don't
don't cause it i was gonna your stomach growling i guess you
it's technically non-lethal he fell on his own he fell on
his own i i didn't kill him he was just clumsy oh my god
these guys are like ash they're just oh technically yeah
technically he's just clumsy clumsy as he's that's on him
that's on him for falling Oh shit, I stepped on the snake
and the snake didn't like it.
That's okay, I think he's all right.
Disgusting.
Alright, off we go.
Okay, it did take us like 30 minutes to get through this one
area, so.
You've been through two, oh yeah, the first area and the
second area.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, watch this.
Okay, this area is really terrible, I'm telling you now.
Oh, did you forget about the...
All right, there you go.
It's stuff.
It's technically stuff.
Go to your map, because you'll want to see the map for this
area.
It's like all the yellow dot all the way up there.
And there's like only certain, like there's little, see how
like there's the, yeah, the, not ditches, what are they
called?
Trenches.
The trenches, yeah.
Sometimes you can get through certain ways in the trenches,
and sometimes you can't.
You got to like...
Okay.
I believe in you.
Yeah, I said I'm on fire.
Yeah, yeah, we gotta get him out of here.
It's the most silent way to kill.
Wait, can I...
Can I shoot that and it'll explode?
Oh, probably.
I think so.
Try.
Oh.
There is a helicopter that's around.
It will attack you if you start, you know.
If you go into alert.
Oh.
Wait, then what's the point?
What if I throw a grenade?
Will it alert me?
Yeah, an explosion will alert you.
Yeah Yep, just RPG it just RPG it just do it.
Oh, but the guy walked away.
It's not worth it Maybe a oh Oh, there is there is Maybe no
Luck 100 oh my god
Stealth stealth stealth I'm stealth.
I'm stealth I I told you, I'm stealthing starting now.
Slowly back away into the pit.
There's guys in here too, by...
Who's that?
Oh, no, no way.
Like, you were gonna...
No, you know what to do.
Did it line up?
Okay, and then...
Oh, did it?
There you go.
And then go torch him.
Yeah.
Oh, you know what?
You're on the same wavelength.
You know what's up.
I know your game.
Look at that.
Guys, she's doing it.
She's doing it.
She's playing the game stealth.
Oh my.
There's a ton of guys around here, by the way.
There's like so many guys over here.
Yeah.
Crazy.
See me?
Try first-person view, that's what I would do.
What?
No!
Oh, your suppressor, your suppressor!
My suppressor!
I didn't realize!
It's too late.
Whoa, shit!
Wait, where'd he go?
Did he get him?
Oh No, oh, no, oh no, it was going so well just stay in the
trenches Oh shit The plane is so fast Do it Yeah, do it
Okay, fuck you Bro, get out of here Get your ass out of here
Wait, wait, alert is going now alert is going on I took I
took it down.
All right, yeah, you took it down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
Everything's going well.
I have the suppressor on.
Plane.
I'm hungry.
That RPG is so...
Oh, wait.
Where do you get poisoned for this?
Oh, you might.
Sick.
Barely noticeable.
Oh, that's fine.
Alright.
That's tasty.
Okay, it was pretty stealthy.
It was stealthy until...
Until...
I forgot to put on the suppressor.
Yeah, that's true.
It was the suppressor's fault.
And I did take down the helicopter.
Alright, maybe he has more food for me.
Wait, is that him?
Where is he?
Wait behind him.
He's right behind me.
No, no, down, down, down, down.
There's nobody down here.
There is a guy.
There was a guy standing there.
I'm just gonna get rid of this.
Really?
He's so fast!
Oh wait, is that food?
What is this?
No.
Oh, no, yeah.
Okay, surely you don't know I'm here, right?
Wait, what?
Oh, never mind.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, they might.
It depends.
No, no, it's fine.
See, they don't know.
Yeah, by the way, you can't go into the next area unless
you're not in an alert mode.
Are you fucking- Okay, okay.
Alright.
Don't worry, I got this.
I'm so stealthy.
Yeah.
Okay, how far am I from the next area?
Oh, I'm almost there.
I'm almost there.
Here we go.
All right.
And then...
Wait, I could technically take down the helicopter.
You could.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Do you think he knows I'm here?
Bombing this area.
I'm going to pee while...
Trust that no one will know.
No, nobody's going to come in.
I trust my house.
I'm going to use the bathroom real quick.
Okay.
She's not...
Oh, okay.
Trust guys, trust.
Trust?
I don't think they'll search during caution.
I think she's fine.
I can hear the guy who's saying that.
He's close.
I don't think they'll come in here.
during caution.
I think she's okay.
That better guy walks in.
See?
I told you.
I told you I was safe.
Look at that.
It's going down.
Yeah!
Look at that.
No one knows.
How could they know?
The Doki strats always work 100% of the time.
Yeah.
As we've, as has been demonstrated.
Nine out of ten times the Doki Strat works 100% of the time.
All right.
Now I go outside.
And then...
No, why?
No.
Get his feet from under the door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the Strat.
Cool.
Oh, is he coming?
Is he coming?
Wait, I know an idea.
Oh,
what's that?
What's that?
Is he not coming?
Well, how will you know if you don't hear?
Oh, he walked away.
They're so stupid.
open oh cqc oh my god i seek you see in front of everybody
awkward why'd you let him go
all right i'll interrogate you
wait how am i interrogating him because you're asking he
will tell you things Oopsie.
Oh, you should have killed him.
You should have killed him when he had the chance.
Oh, shit.
Oh, okay, it's fine.
I have an idea.
Oh, oh, why your ass?
Why?
I have an idea.
Why don't you just keep CQ seeing them?
Oh, I told you it just happened.
It worked.
fire I told you it worked oh oh oh set them all on fire set
the world on fire oh shit okay don't worry you didn't see
them open the door don't worry it'll work oh my god let me
set them on fire at least come on Come on.
There we go.
There it is.
And then...
Oh yeah.
They'll never know.
And then watch this.
Okay, not that.
Not that.
Watch this.
I'm gonna be like... BAM!
And then...
Holy fuck, how many people are shooting me?
Oh, they broke the door!
Not my door!
Oh man.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Do I have to keep watching or...
No, no, no, no.
Watch this.
It's going to work.
And then...
Oh, shit.
I can't...
How do you...
Oh, my God.
Why am I...
Snake, get up, get up, get up.
Snake, please.
I'm...
No!
Oh, he's dead.
Okay.
How did the guy die?
No!
That's okay.
Watch this.
Wait, he didn't...
He will go down eventually, you know.
Like, you could just wait.
You could have patience and, like, they'll eventually get...
They'll have...
You don't have to keep shooting.
Oh!
Nice.
Yeah.
Alright.
See, okay, now... Now stealth mode starts now.
Set him on fire.
Yeah, you know the drill.
You know the drill.
all right and then just like last time i'll be right back
i'm gonna get a snack
it works nine or ten times it works a hundred percent of the
time just like that
starting now
stealth Okay.
Oh, oh, I didn't mean to pick him up.
Oh, I didn't mean to pick him up.
Oh, free loot though.
Okay, like that fire.
And then burn!
There we go.
Stealth.
And then watch this.
we go into my little house my little stealth house I grab
some more ammo and then I eat some food.
Oh my god.
And then look, I'm making it.
Look at that.
I learned my lesson.
I learned how I learned my lesson.
Look at that.
Look, look.
We're still here.
There's a hole to your left.
It could go in there if you wanted.
Wait, there is?
There's no hole.
No.
No, in the trench.
Oh.
I see it.
All right.
But no bump.
Wait, does it not take me back to downstairs?
Oh, yeah.
Well, I mean.
I didn't tell you where it would go.
I'm just saying there's a hole.
Oh, you mean the other hole over here that takes me upstairs
instead?
I mean, that's, I mean, you can go into any little hole that
you want.
Yeah, all right, all right.
Someone doesn't know their lefts and right.
This is a little freaky.
Oh my god, where are they?
No!
Get his face!
Because it's a trick!
Immediately pulls out the RPGs.
Nice.
If I'm going down, I'm taking him down with me.
Alright.
Oh no, oh no, where do I hide?
Okay.
Push my torch.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, there.
Just leave him.
You're not even- It's not even lit!
No man left behind!
Oh shit!
Okay, maybe one man left behind.
Oh!
Friendly fire?
No man- Now keep going to- keep going to your- right?
Yeah, turn- go straight.
There you go.
A man left behind.
It's okay, it's okay.
Everything is fine.
It's just one helicopter.
It's just one tiny little helicopter.
That's tasty.
All right.
And now that I'm fully recovered.
Well, your stamina is fully recovered, not your health.
Now that I'm fully recovered.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck?
It's okay.
This is no man's land.
Look, look, guys.
Just get out of the alert.
We did it.
Yay!
Yeah.
Oh, see, I told you.
I'm not good at stealth.
Might be the most stealthy player in Metal Gear Solid.
How did I let you win?
Never punished.
What can I say?
Oh!
Mommy?
Whoa!
Oh god, oh yeah, she needs to breathe through her skin.
She's pretty quiet.
It's the beta test.
Hasn't left me much time to sleep.
Where'd you get those cuts?
The Colonel.
He found out.
If he knew I'd be dead already.
No, this is his hobby.
He's a sadist.
Oh shit.
Yeah, he's freaky.
That's a freaky man.
Whoa.
Oh, yeah.
I'm the same way.
Scars all over.
The Croc mask is just too sexy.
Where'd you get this one?
I got it after defecting to the Soviet Union.
I don't think so.
It's older than that.
Code breaking is a desk job.
Where'd you get this kind of scar?
Yeah.
You're not a cracker.
You want to know how I got these scars?
Yeah.
A girl's got to have some secrets here.
She's like...
It's like in her head.
These two trials, a shaggle hot is about to start.
And it looks like someone might be coming to spoil the
party.
The master is on.
The colonel is gathering his troops together to meet them.
If we don't get a move on, the security will be even
tighter.
than it is now.
You'll need this key.
It unlocks the door to the underground tunnel.
Once you're in there, you can follow the tunnel to get
inside Groznygrad.
Oh, yeah, Groznygrad.
Oh, hey, ramen.
How did she get Japanese ramen?
What is this?
What are these funny characters?
Food of the future.
It's good to eat some real food once in a while.
Instant ramen.
I know.
Don't forget the R1.
Oh.
I'll bet if I kissed you.
You taste like a wild beast.
Fucking crock the towel.
Do you know where exactly in Grosnagrad, Sokolov is located?
He's in the heart of the fortress, the weapons lab.
The weapons lab is divided into three wings.
Oh my god.
Here comes my man.
The man.
Yeah, Raikov.
That's where the Shadowhawk is.
Finally, there's the West Wing which is connected via a
passageway to the main building.
That's where Sokolov is.
To get in, you'll have to enter the main wing from the East
Wing.
Then go through the passageway on the second floor of the
main wing.
The West Wing of the Weapons Lab.
Oh, got it.
There's just one problem.
Not again.
The West Wing is protected by the highest level of security.
You need to be Colonel class to get in Colonel class Here,
look at this picture.
Major Ivan Rydanovich Rykov Pretend you're him.
I'm right.
I'm pretending to be Russian Yeah, you're pretending to be
this dude.
Oh Fuck.
You're pretending to be Volgan's lover His little his twink.
Yeah, you're pretending to be his Twink, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, there's a little boy toy.
Break up!
You're gonna like this part.
Is that me?
That will be you.
You gotta steal his clothes.
Oh, I'm gonna strip him, aren't that?
Yep.
He's a little meow meow.
Get Sokolov out of there.
Command said you're supposed to have something ready for me.
And I do.
It's our little sensor, you know, the black eye sensor bar.
I know, it's too, like, cinematic.
I can't fly one of those.
That's okay.
I happen to be an excellent pilot.
Oh, yeah.
Taking off from a lake is trickier than it looks.
It's not like riding a motorcycle.
You've got to be more delicate.
Of course I will.
You've seen how good I am with the bike, right?
yeah I saw her fucking ran someone over why did she look at
the shoes you handle the escape then I'll head for Groznik
rad wait a minute oh something I wanted to ask you yeah
what's my number what's the story between you and the boss
my mommy she jealous
she's there
love her how deep does it go oh do you love her oh wait
she's a milk chaser does it have to be one or the other love
or hate oh he's indifferent between a man and a woman
he like turns away from her yeah and you think you can kill
her now
She wants that croc.
Don't say that.
It's very true though.
Well, she likes it.
The croc cat like opening its mouth every time.
Yeah, girl.
I've never been interested in other people's lives.
You were interested.
i'm the main character she was different damn how do you
feel about me i should be asking you the same question if
it's part of the mission if am i part of the mission even
with you oh r1 r1 r1 Oh,
just a peck.
Snake?
He's not reciprocating.
Oh, she's like, my first kiss.
Look at him, he's just standing there.
He's like, his first kiss.
Like, oh, no, goodies.
Oh, no, goodies.
What's wrong?
I never learned to kiss in the mission.
This wasn't in the guidebook.
Mommy didn't teach me this.
Mommy.
Mommy?
Why did you teach me this, Mommy?
Oh.
This part, this part's good.
Yeah, Grozny Grand.
See you around, Snake.
Take care of yourself.
What about you?
CQK.
Are you going to be okay?
Not sure.
They're not stupid.
They know there's a spy.
There's no way you could have gotten that.
What's that supposed to mean?
The guy in the standing like totally bloodied up with his
crock hat on.
Damn.
Ma'am, your jacket is still zipped down, ma'am.
What's going on over there?
oh i have to infiltrate the russian base
oh there he is oh he is oh oh my god you're so angry
Wait, there was a person in there?
Oh shit.
Ripperoni.
Oh, I think he's dead, dead.
Granite!
It's grandpa!
No.
He can't put legs on tanks anymore!
No!
His dream!
Do we think he's okay?
What's that?
That tracker in his shoes.
Huh?
Exactly.
Planted to keep someone informed of his location.
Oh, shit.
Does this mean Granon was the spy?
perhaps he was being used by someone else perhaps this man
was our comrade comrade or not he's of no use to us now I
mean he's dead so yeah I don't need your approval oh he has
daddy and mommy issues and that nuclear shell still feeling
sore about that are you what are you gonna do report it to
the authorities This is war, Major.
The Cold War.
Caught with information and espionage.
Not the Cold War.
Spies wherever they hide.
Look at his thighs, man.
Potential threats must be weeded out.
Your feelings are a mess.
This is the unity of our organization.
Someone is guiding the enemy's hand.
A single man can only accomplish so much.
make no mistake there is a spy among us but casting
suspicion among us the c3 explosives have been stolen you
think it was the american no he could not have reached this
fortress yet then who who could it be the boys mommy mommy
where have you been she's like no we're Oh no, I'm just...
Oh my god, wait, that's...
I just noticed that that's her.
It's like Superman where you put the glasses on.
It is!
It works!
She put on the glasses and
I...
He's good.
Oh.
I'll take care of him What is he after this guy's what did
you think that they that they were talking about when he was
like oh, yeah This is from vulgan.
I don't know.
I thought it's just some oh man.
It's pretty fucked.
That's fucked up man.
I wonder when that happened
Huh?
Why the fuck did she bring a horse to kill me as well?
That's her horse colonel tighten the security on this place
He's coming here.
I'm sure of it.
I'm going to get the Davy Crockett.
The Davy Crockett.
I thought that's in America.
No, the thing that...
Oh, the giant...
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Clark Kent is Superman.
No way.
But it works!
The glasses!
She put on glasses.
I could never tell.
Yeah.
smells oh she smells like him he recognizes it
he's like i recognize the scent of my man this is wearing
perfume
nice boots
They're scuffed.
There's sand on it.
Yeah, finger guns.
He's such a little loser.
I love this so much.
Yeah, no, he's definitely the bottom.
Oh.
Okay, so bad news.
You have to go back through that previous area you were just
at.
No, surely I can...
Oh.
Yeah.
No.
Where do I go from there?
So there's going to be a red door.
Okay.
That you go to.
That door?
Also, search this area because you'll get stuff.
Oh, yeah, ramen noodles.
Yeah, get your noodles.
Get your stuff down there, dear.
Oh, yeah, there's the red door.
Yeah.
The one that you walk through to get to the previous area.
Alright.
And now...
Where the fuck is that?
It's like a little past the, um...
The storage room that you were in.
Alright.
Don't worry, I'm stealthing.
Surely there's no more defense down here, right?
Oh yeah, those guys are long gone.
Yeah, yeah, I'm pretty sure.
Okay, so the guys are gone, right?
Who's that?
Oh yeah, the fire, um, the flamethrowers?
So, the fire, I guess.
I did warn you about those guys.
To be fair.
All right.
I'm ready.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
There we go.
Nice.
That's fine.
I'll just head down.
Nice.
Oh.
All right.
Nice.
There we go.
I would just climb up there.
Really?
Alright.
Wait, where is it?
Down here?
Oh, there's more guys.
Yeah.
Yeah, where are they?
Thank you.
There it is.
Alright.
So you're playing Apex!
Not Apex.
Oh, what do you play now?
Rivals!
No, this is just Apex.
Oh yeah, so you're playing Apex!
Oh, hey, there's a bird.
Yeah.
All right.
Nice shot.
It's like right below there.
All right, that means I can just...
Come in, HQ.
Yeah, just drop down.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
Control here.
We've lost the enemy.
All right.
Like it.
Now, just drop down.
Just drop down.
Yeah, but I just wanted to...
Oh, oh, you missed.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Yay.
Yay, easy.
Yay!
It's just that easy.
Look at that.
All right.
Now, now back to control.
All right, back to stealth.
And remember how there was like the Cobra unit.
Yeah.
Yeah, there was like one guy left.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Was he?
Wait, you missed an item.
Oh, yeah, I see.
I see it.
So who is the last guy?
Oh, it's a grenade.
You'll see.
Oh, it's just grenade.
Just kidding.
Yeah.
Oh, I should find more food.
It's fine.
time yeah ramen time delicious all right one last pokemon
that the boss has oh yeah yeah
i don't even i can't even realize he had one more i thought
the end was the last one because he's the end no there's a
bunch of items around here by the way why the fuck is he the
end then when he's the end yeah but he wasn't the end so is
he really the end if he never ended well yeah he's the end
like he's the end you just have to understand you just have
to get it alright good luck this one's actually not so bad
in this game but I believe he can do it that's the last guy
right The last Pokemon.
And then I'll whip you in the Leaf 4.
Oh.
Oh, is he fire type?
Yeah, he's fire type.
Space.
Wait, he has a helmet?
That's cheating!
He's spaceman!
Bro, Glass is not going to protect you from a bullet.
He looks so cool.
Oh my god.
He is among us.
I am the fury.
Oh, the fury.
Yes.
Why are you so mad?
I came back from space.
He came back from space.
I had one vision.
The world set ablaze.
And do you know what I saw this?
Chad, doesn't he kind of look like the Luden's mascot now?
The what mascot?
Kojima's, like, mascot.
Oh, he's the skeleton boy.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God, you can fly?
Yeah.
He has a jet pack.
Now, you're going to feel the scorching heat of that
horrible blackness.
Oh shit!
Ah yeah!
Alright, let me grab my AK.
Oh, sure.
Let me grab my AK.
Um, oh wait.
And RPG might work also.
Where is he?
Oh my god!
There's him!
Where is he?
Where would- what do you- how far does this fire go?
Pretty far.
It goes down the whole tunnel.
Oh.
That's not good.
I see him.
He's right there.
You see him?
He peeked out on me.
Yeah, I did see him too.
What is he doing?
He just kind of like walks up and down the aisles.
What?
He just walks around.
He's just walking around.
Where did he go?
Hello?
Fury?
Knock knock?
I thought you were mad.
not mad no more oh there he is there he is oh that does oh
it did nothing yeah did nothing yeah just shoot okay i
didn't feel a thing literally all right well where are you
walking now you're still walk here what what the fuck Where
did that come from?
Oh.
Oh, he flies.
I keep forgetting that.
There we go.
Oh, my God.
Oh, didn't catch me.
We're too slow.
Where did he go?
Oh, shit.
Just keep him down.
Keep him down.
Oh shit Oh shit I got too distracted Wait that was literally
the straw That was so good Oh my god
Bro Bro, maybe he's not good at his job That's all I'll say
He's not that good at his job man Pretty bad at him.
I'm not going to lie.
He's very bad at his job.
You're bullying him.
Don't use the RPG.
It's not worth it.
But I tapped all more ammo.
Oh, sure.
Oh, I have this.
I don't remember what gun this was.
I don't know.
Wait, where is he?
Actually, the Fury deserves to be bullied.
This guy's ass.
miss where is he hello hurry he's running around oh he's
scared down come on oh oh oh boy he's my feet there yeah oh
shoot oh shoot shotgun him shotgun oh shit oh shit oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god i see oh my god i'm getting up
yeah you might want to kill oh yeah maybe maybe i should
cure myself i i lost i lost myself in the sauce i oh i used
everything uh you know what what the last shot wait no the
last shot should be
where is he where is he oh i hear him oh i hear out oh
shit that's pretty hardcore like self-destructed himself
they all have kind of done that yeah oh my god the flames of
fury the fires of hell will purge me clean oh oh shit yeah
he's okay i can see it see what mission control do you read
me he's thinking about his his previous mission he's coming
home oh I see the earth oh oh damn Damn.
Oh yeah.
Wait, there's ghosts now too?
Yeah.
It's just, that's just how it goes.
Wait, what the fuck?
The Russian invented ghosts?
The mummy?
Yeah.
Bro, what the fuck?
Wait, which came first?
The mummy or this game?
Yes, it's always the movie first.
Oh yeah, that goes Kojima.
He's just like, oh, yeah.
Yeah, he loves the mummy.
Oh, I gotta get my Instagrammin in.
He loves the mummy.
If only Twitter was around, so you could have shared his
mummy review.
Oh, I know.
Oh, there's more stuff here too.
Ooh, nice.
Alright, I gotta go- You missed some more behind you too.
Yeah, wait, I gotta kill this rat real quick.
Wait, come on.
Come on, don't run away from me.
Come on.
Come on, I need mom.
Oh, mama needs some food.
Alright.
Alright, I'll grab this.
Oh, never mind.
Got this, though.
And then...
Yes.
More heels.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Come on, Snake.
It's not that hard.
Come on.
What are you doing?
Come on, climb the ladder.
He can't see it's the big old crocodile.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the crocodile has, you know.
Yeah.
He does not want to take it off.
No.
It goes with the aesthetic.
It's a strong ass hat.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Ooh.
Oh shit Welcome to Groznygrad I'm a Groznygrad Look at the
cockpit You remember what you need to do right?
Yeah, I got a cockpit I'm gonna strip him And you have that
mask The mask?
Of his face Oh yeah, I remember Yeah, yeah, yeah Wait,
that's riding Yeah!
Oh my God, wait, Raiden was his boyfriend?
Was his twin's boyfriend?
No, it's Raikov.
It's Raikov.
Oh, Raikov.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, his Russian name.
Common mistake.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's like his Russian alias.
No, they're different people.
Wait, what?
This is Raikov, yeah.
Okay, what do I have?
Are we stealthing?
Yeah, we are.
Watch this.
Oh, oh.
I watched.
I definitely saw something happen.
You're not, clearly you're not watching it clear.
Oh my god, might as well reset.
I know.
Just kill me.
You could just die, you'll reset.
Yeah, yeah, just kill me.
Come on, I'll even present the butt.
Come on.
Come on, shoot me.
I'm so easy.
Present yourself.
No, please, Mr. God, I'm begging to die.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just waving a clock on the ground.
Come on.
Just shoot me.
I'm so vulnerable right now.
Just come on.
Come on.
Come on, don't come on.
It really shows just how much you need to take to die in
this game.
Jesus Christ.
How long does it take?
He's a strong guy.
He tanks it.
Damn.
Nanomachines, man.
Alright.
Okay.
Watch this.
We're real this time.
Wait, his back is turned.
That was a different guy you went for.
more than one what the hell what are you doing i will start
doing the bullet you know like you're a suppressor that's
why you're suppressor okay he doesn't know he don't know
watch
this see still no
You still?
Music is so good, guys.
I don't.
You can get under these.
You can crawl under them.
Wait, I can.
Yeah.
Wait, where are the others?
That's a great question, actually.
Where did they go?
Where did they all go?
You should look around before you crawl out.
Okay, never mind.
That's fine.
We're just going for it.
Set him on fire.
my set him out fire here we go my god don't yell so loud he
scares okay it's okay nobody knows yeah nobody knows nobody
knows i'm so stealthy we did oh oh wait can i shoot them
from here if i shoot you could shoot like his ankles and
then he'll like yeah did i get him yeah did i got him
is he gonna sleep i can't tell if i got him or not Where'd
he go?
He, like, ran off.
Wait, where did he go?
He actually, like, disappeared over there.
Wait.
Oh, gosh.
The other guy is still there, isn't he?
He burned, but...
Oh.
Oh, lucky.
Wait, can I drag him in here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You could.
Or, actually, I don't know if he'll fit.
Will he fit in here?
Like, if you can do...
No, I don't think so.
That was lucky, though.
You could probably, like, push him under there yeah yeah i
was thinking yeah yeah yeah okay wait i'm gonna you have to
like turn around and push them in yeah and i'll do like i
wonder if it'll work yeah let me try to see and then like
push him in push him in oh wait oops oops i mean he still
has time i'll push him in i don't know if it'll work oh it
doesn't all right well burning time Sorry, guys.
We tried.
We wanted him to...
Well, he wasn't going to live regardless.
Can you, like, push him from the front?
I don't think so.
Yeah, I did.
I tried.
Yeah.
Like, we all...
I mean, he wasn't going to live regardless.
I was just wanted to hide his body.
You can hide them in, like, lockers and stuff, but...
Oh, yeah.
I don't think there's a locker near me.
No.
Alright.
I would check the map and see where you got to go.
Oh, that's true.
Alright.
over there.
Grab this loot.
Uh-huh.
See, guys, I can still.
Look at that.
Are you, like, used to not, like, looking where you're
going?
Do you just, like, do you, like, never check ever?
Is that just how you play games?
There's, like, pure instinct, you know?
I didn't hit him.
I don't need to check when I could feel them.
You can feel them.
I can feel it.
Nice.
I don't think you have to kill each one.
I don't have to.
Don't give you a river.
Think of your river.
What river?
I thought we already bypassed the river.
With a sniper.
What are you talking about?
Okay.
You know where to go?
Oh.
Wait, let me loot him real quick.
Oh, he had nothing of value.
Just like his life.
I am.
Yeah, through that door right there.
That door?
Yeah.
Right over there.
Nope.
To the right.
Guys, I stealthed an entire level!
I did it!
Now we're like, oh, it's just running.
here i could just run there that guy oh he's just there are
there are spotlights they'll get you okay but does the door
close if i get detected what do you mean oops
like if i just run it run for it oh well i mean they will
like come in hq no oh i'm so hungry I'm so hungry.
Good thing you got that red.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Just ignore him.
No.
You got him.
I got him.
Okay.
I can just...
Wait, where is he?
Okay, I'm running for it.
It's like right over there.
Yeah, yeah.
But watch out for the spotlight.
Okay.
Oh Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, right over there.
Oh, did you see that other guy?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, watch this right?
I wish you'd stop saying that
It's just Aha, okay You know what I'm just gonna Oh, all
right to the to the left to the left.
Oh, wait Yeah, there go in there Go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go.
Alright, time to find a guy and strip him of his clothes.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Wait, this guy.
He's literally in front of me.
No, that was not him.
I can't strip this guy.
It has to be specifically him.
It has...
Yeah, because it's his uniform.
He's right there.
He's so strippable.
That was not him.
Yeah, but what if he has to...
something cooler he might but that's not wreck of okay but i
just wanted oh see see see he had ammo he had ammo all right
now mouse trap oh oops my gosh why is square burn and oh hey
double loot nice all right nice all right i don't think they
heard his screams of pain i'm pretty sure we're fine Yeah,
probably.
No, knock, knock.
I like that your camo is negative five.
That's perfect.
He sometimes does go to the bathroom and you could get him
in there.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
For now.
Okay.
Here's the thing, though.
You're going to get this guy, and you're going to have to
bring him upstairs.
What?
That's damn good.
Are you fucking kidding me?
and see if he's upstairs honestly there's a staircase right
there yeah just be careful there's yeah i'm fine see oh my
god i literally hear somebody walking my little pitty patter
you nobody here oh my god there's like nobody came to work
today actually no one went to work
hey where is everybody actually what the fuck uh keep going
around what yeah where is everyone yeah vacation day hello
who's calling me that door can't be opened by normal means
apparently it operates by responding to a specific frequency
if you want to know the key frequency why don't you try
asking someone nearby bye oh i killed everybody it's fine if
you get his uniform you can just go through it okay i knew
here wait oh everybody locked their lockers wait is that him
oh there's a guy over there no that's not him wait i heard
you heard that right i hear shuffling but like you heard
that right i think my audio is desynced so no no no i heard
a guy go oh oh there is a guy outside the door i saw him not
outside the door but can you see me if i'm here can you see
me through the glass it's it's like not it's like one way
right oh oh one way yeah we just kill him when he comes in
yeah one way or another but i know no no getcha getcha
getcha getcha one way or another where the fuck is this guy
i think he went into that room right there yeah oh what was
that noise at home he's gonna we just sleep go find rikov go
find them well i find them when you come to me he might be
he might not be here i don't he's gonna he might go be in
the party why is he having a pee break on company time he's
like he's like second in command he's high rank it doesn't
matter what he does yeah we know how he got his rank yeah we
do yeah we do go find him okay give me a sec i can't open
that door it requires radio frequencies then go back the way
you gave i don't want to what do you want me to say tell me
the radio frequency that's not my information i don't even
know it i'll be honest i don't care hey babe oh my god you
could just drop down see if he's up around or i don't know
holy shit bro where is this man he's probably taking a dump
cut that oh i can sound the oh wait was that him what's that
i don't think so but all right who was that why don't you go
see should go see who it was why are you facing the wall
open the door and then i'll be like pop pop wait who saw me
anyway that's why i said go see who saw you it might have
been him wait nobody saw me what don't you there's no one
there's no one there do you see this god no i see nobody
like that nobody is here
Alright, I'm heading over.
I'm heading back downstairs.
Oh, wait, that's him.
There he is, there he is, there he is.
That's him, that's him, that's him, that's him, that's him,
that's him.
You think he'll see me if I have...
See, that was him!
Oh my god, he doesn't know.
Do you think he'll come in?
Yeah, but he'll sound an alarm, wouldn't he?
You're A and Doki.
I got him you're gonna have to wait until it's over all
right now drag him to the lockers I got him I got him guys I
got him oh shit oh shit oh shit give me a sec okay we got
him but at what cost maybe the shotgun would be good here
because you're really close to them oh that is true but also
oh wait i think i didn't you didn't even equip it okay maybe
you're right i should have just got the shotgun where's the
shotgun there we go there you go see it's fine it's fine
non-leasful all right now wait wait wait wait before we grab
him i might have to i might have to do this again What are
you?
Oh, no, no, he's going to wake up.
No, no, he's not.
No, he's not.
Oh, that's... Oh, um...
Who fucking shot me?
Oh.
Splash damage.
Don't keep thinking of the splash damage.
It's fine.
I'll do this.
There we go.
See, see it works.
It works.
There we go.
And then...
Just to be sure.
all right you're gonna take him to his locker and put him in
there how do i know which one's his uh that's what you gotta
figure out how the fuck which one is special oh the one
that's red she can see she can see it's red for for Ryden,
Rykoff.
Rykoff!
Yeah.
Check out the poster in there.
Why is it not opening?
You gotta wait until... There you go.
Now you got it.
Yeah.
You have to wait until the evasion or whatever.
Oh, it's so easy.
I did a stealthily, too.
Oh my god.
Skin-on-skin contact.
Oh my god, he's wearing a fucking speed up.
Oh shit, he has a poster of himself, bro.
What the fuck?
Sam, I would, I do too.
Hey!
Now how do I become him?
The costume.
Oh, is it, oh, is it in my camouflage?
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
Officer, and then do the face too.
All right, now I'm him.
welcome to um easy mode you can do no no no no no not yet
don't don't go yet don't go yet go out and like you have you
have free reign right now you can you can do anything you
want you can like punch them you can wait really you yes
they they have to follow you yeah so wait can i shoot go
toward i don't i don't think it'll let you equip your weapon
oh yeah that's but you can do anything all right oh all the
bodies are gone too and you can go like loot everything and
oh yeah it must be loot here yeah do anything you want oh
hey nerd that's like you're right that's right yeah yeah
yeah yeah Oh yeah, come on salute me back.
Yes.
Come on salute me.
If they don't salute you back I beat them up.
Yeah, exactly.
Do you not love the motherland?
Huh?
Yeah.
You don't love your country.
That's looking right, nerd.
What are you?
American?
Yeah.
Filthy American.
Oh shit, sorry.
Yeah.
Can I like... Oh, I'm hungry.
Oh, I'm out of food i should have i should have killed more
vultures i want some more well they like oh thank you
oh scorpion let's go can i loot them you can like grab them
and like all right do you have any all right give me your
lunch money that's looking right give me your lunch money
nice he did rob them of all their worth i'm not robbing them
we're sharing uh loot it is mother russia yeah yeah yeah
we're all sharing loot right now i think there was one other
door on the other side and then got everything all right yo
give me your lunch money give me your fucking lunch money
Yeah, what's going on?
What the fuck is going on?
And then they'll be like, oh, it's you, sir.
It's you, sir.
I can go in first person.
Oh, yeah.
And like punch them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
So fun.
Give me your lunch money.
I'm so hungry.
All right.
Pat.
Do it, do it, do it.
Yeah, do it, do it.
No, no, just the one punch.
wine punch all right wait the fine work sir oh i have to oh
i thought a crouch punch but i guess not no crouch punch
allowed i shouldn't you should no when i'm crouching down
doesn't let me yeah standing punches only
all the nerds are yeah yeah that's looking right yeah that's
right why are you running torture them torture them these
little snakes that's looking right that's what you get nerds
you think just because you're not in high school anymore
yeah i won't stop you in the locker wait go in the first
person and like keep standing and aim down and then you'll
you should be there's that one guy over all right all right
get up where is he get up oh he's crying are you gonna pee
your pants are you gonna pee are you gonna pee your pants
yeah what all right stand up one punch the one punch come on
yeah stand up and just oh oh need me thank you for the rain
oh um uh we're not doing anything bad we're not bullying
people yeah yeah yeah yeah no no these guys these you know
we're just um he was choking and i was trying to help i was
trying to help them you know they were choking and
everything i was giving them a high maneuver like in the
front in the front big hug big hug yeah yeah big hug no hard
feelings no hard feelings i'll be like you like oh hey oh
man you know you did oh he's shaking with excitement guys oh
you did a great job here boom Great work, soldier.
Great work.
You know what?
You're doing great.
Oh, nothing.
Just say how good he's been doing in his job.
Right, Mint?
Yeah.
See, like, you know, bros being like give a punch on the
shoulder being like, you're a great bro.
Yeah, yeah.
It's just a friendly little tap.
Yeah, a funny little tap.
Yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
All right.
Nice one, bro.
Nice one.
Oh, oh, um, he tripped, guys.
He tripped.
Did I see that?
Ah, clumsy.
Yeah, he's so clumsy, everyone.
Oh, man.
We call him clumsy Carl.
Yeah, clumsy Carl.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, he has a little...
He's just out of his antics again.
He has, like, a little medical issue where, like, if you,
like, push him a little bit, he, like, tips over, you know?
We gotta be very careful with him, you know?
We call him Clunky Jero You can go outside too, by the way
Yeah, but I want loot here Also, he told me He told me that
to pick up his stuff If he ever falls down You know, because
he has a fragile thing So I'm just I'm just doing a I'm
just, you know, helping a homie out Alright, I think we can
go now Lucky Alright, I've got some medical equipment Does
he not wake up?
No when you put a soldier in a locker they don't wake up oh
oh i can oh yeah these other ones some of them do open yeah
i was gonna say do they open yeah and you can also kick them
open too oh oh i don't think i can i guess not now oh nice i
might as well oh yeah more food wait i need that yeah i need
that i'm hungry
all right that's fine let's just go then yeah they like
being in the locker Yeah, it's comfy and nice.
There's a pillow in there, too.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, you can't go in there yet.
Look, look in there.
Oh, wait.
That's the...
Is that the tank with legs?
Or is that the other thing?
The tank without legs, yeah.
Oh, the tank without legs.
Oh, yeah, because we killed him.
So he could never...
He could never get his dream tank made.
Nope.
It will never, ever happen.
Oh, no.
never happen poor guy that's all he wanted a fucking tank
with legs yeah it will never be it will never come to
fruition ever salute it is salute you know what that means
oh oh yeah
one of the best cut scenes of the game oh is it i'll raise
the volume up i love that you can tell it's a mask like when
you see his neck and everything is so funny.
Here it is.
You can count on me.
What about the philosopher's legacy?
I don't know anything about that.
What are you?
Are you trying to kill me?
What's the matter?
I know nothing.
I swear it.
No one but the colonel knows of the legacy.
of death kiss of death oh my god she's gonna kiss her at
least he gets to go like you know he gets the final kiss i
know before he dies right you know yeah blind
tatiana how could she not see him run off this man is he's
built like a wall how could you not i know it's like those
shoes are making a tippy tappy noise yeah you're the man
from the cia it's me what are you doing here i told you
before didn't i i'm going to get you out of here honor just
like your commander but i'm afraid you're too late too late
too late tell me the shag of huds Uh-oh.
Spaghetti-oh.
Preparations for phase two are complete.
There's still phase three, right?
Phase two.
Maybe there's a phase three.
It's a composite range extension system for medium range
ballistic missiles.
I feel like it's time to go.
The game audio is really quiet.
I feel like this game's audio balancing is all over the
place.
It really is.
Yeah.
That could launch nuclear missiles from any time.
of terrain it's phase three profit we couldn't figure out
how to solve the icbms we have today are simply too big for
the shagohod to carry but the military would not hear of it
they demanded a weapon that could launch a nuclear missile
directly into the american homeland that is when i came up
with the idea for phase two phase two but there's no way you
could load an cbm onto the shagohod so how do you do it by
accelerating the shagohod itself oh accelerating it it
doesn't make it go really fast it just has to go super duper
fast the unit incorporates the same technology used in the
Vostok rocket that sent major Gagarin into space you can do
the shagohod i can achieve a land speed of over 300 miles
per hour That monster can go more than 300 miles per hour.
Holy shit, that's really fast!
From this state of accelerated motion, it launches a nuclear
missile.
But like, how does that help?
Shagohod acts like the first stage of a rocket.
Oh!
Yeah.
The range of the missile launched by the Shagohod thus
increases from...
And then it has its little parachute to stop it.
I feel like...
That doesn't actually work.
I feel like physics wise that I think I'll recalculate the
math here.
All you need is three miles every time you want to launch a
rocket.
It's like a plane.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
It's like a missile plane.
Also, the parachute seems way too tiny.
There were three of them.
Yeah, three pairs.
One plus one plus one equals one big pair, too.
A completed prototype now sits in the hangar.
At present, it is the only one of its kind.
But Vulcan is planning to mass-produce them based on...
Everybody will be making their own three-mile...
Three-mile raft.
Yes, but that's not the end of it.
He's going to ship them to...
surveying like through satellite like who's building a three
mile runway okay but what if it's four miles undetectable
undetectable his funds are nearly limitless he could start
mass production tomorrow if he wanted the reason that
tensions between east and west have settled into a cold war
is because each side fears the other's power deterrence
deterrence using threats to keep one's enemy in check is the
perfect word to sum up this state of affairs but the
shagohan goes far beyond the level of threat it will render
the concept of deter yeah by the way don't keep this is like
a really long cut oh my god it's longer than the intro it
will not be long there's no way there's no way that's not i
think it's like a half hour long
All right, I paused a little.
Oh, wait, it's not paused.
Oops, sorry.
I wanted to up the thing a little bit more.
So you see, it's already too late.
I hope it's not too loud.
It's not too late.
What do you mean?
We've still got a chance.
All we have to do is destroy the prototype and the whole
facility before they can mass produce it.
But just tell me what I need to do to do.
destroy this place all right the liquid fuel used in the
rocket engine is stored in a tank if you can blow it up
somehow or is that easy some c3 ought to be enough to blow
the entire hangar to smith just get some c3 baby you mean
that cutting-edge plastic explosive it could be molded into
any shape the bomb of the future We're getting all sorts of
things in the future.
We got ramen.
Calorie, mate.
No, that's not her name.
Her name is Tatiana.
Tatiana!
By becoming Vulcan's lover.
I thought she was your lover.
How many lovers does she have?
Oh my god, we're gonna finally see his wife.
Wait, but what?
I thought she was.
Oh, okay.
What does she look like?
Check out his wife.
What's wrong with his wife?
Who are they?
They?
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Are they okay?
Are they ghosts?
Like, are they ghosts?
Like...
Did he know they're ghosts?
He finally saw her, the ugly one!
Bro, it looks like some phasophobia shit.
Does he know?
Does he have?
Like, when you take a picture and then the ghost distorts
the fucking face, like shit.
She saw the tape.
She has seven days left.
I'm not going.
Like, She went to bed.
She went to bed.
to into the grudge house oh no oh no not kusha i would most
certainly be sent to the gulags uh what about the us they're
always looking for scientists yeah yeah he's done it for
years but even if i fled to the united states i would once
again find myself creating weapons of mass murder yeah oh
144.75 what it was on the thing where are these freaky
numbers you're speaking of the codec to be honest with you
i'm tired oh so beloved oh it's like the things that should
never be used things that should never is it called the the
nuclear bomb movie without he's like that guy oh openheimer
he's openheimer he's russian openheimer do not even benefit
mankind
this is a common theme in metal gear he's barbie he's barbie
yeah it's barbie hiber oh he just wanted to be going to
space the prey of politicians the space race and the arms
race are one and the same missiles rockets what's the
difference scientists are always being used
oh my god like i i didn't even if he didn't say daughter i
would not think that was like a child I don't know why the
picture is so messed up looking Yeah, yeah It's like an
actual cursed family Oh, vulgar Let's go, it's time Oh god,
he's gotta wear his mask He's ready for his lover His boy
toy Oh yeah
Major What are you doing here?
I've been waiting for you in my room
Oh boy!
Oh shit!
Oh again?
He's gotta confirm.
He's got it.
No, he got it.
He's very familiar with it.
So is he bigger or smaller?
Is he...
I know that means you.
Look, he took lots of pills, you know?
He just saw the eyes.
He took the...
You know, the opener, shake this pill, get bigger.
Oh, my God!
What?
Poor Sokolov.
Did he like what he see?
Like, did he...
What he felt?
Yeah, yeah, did he like what he felt?
Is that why they shoot the knee?
He's like, I don't want anyone interrupting.
Oh shit.
In the mask is so funny.
Yeah, I would feel like it's not good for freezing.
What if he's by?
Whoa, can she call him that?
What if?
Can she call him that?
Stay out of this.
She's so awesome.
She just took down every man in this room.
Well, to be fair, this guy was not much of a challenge.
You got his knees shot.
I see why they call you the boss.
What was that?
You're so cool.
No, it's CQC.
Basic form of close quarters combat.
He and I developed it together.
Splendid.
I'll take it from here.
Oh shit.
Are you going to kill him?
I don't like this part.
Of course.
But first...
What?
I will make him pay for hurting Ivan.
Oh no!
Oh!
You hurt his lover and stripped him of his clothes.
Oh, he's like, only I could see him naked.
Yeah, he's like, how dare you touch him?
Did you see his lightning bolt tidy whitties?
Those beetles were for me.
Oh, my God.
I saw just hanging outside.
We're hurting his little poopy bear.
Oh, no.
snake he's like my future boyfriend oh he's trying to stay
up it's so bad that's
oh say tap out tap out it's so
bad guys jake paul
Jake Paul wishes he could be a fraction of a man.
No, no, it's a punch!
It's a jaw punch!
Oh my god, there's so much blood.
Wait, whose blood is it?
I'm pretty sure it's Snake's blood.
That's a concussion right there.
Oh yeah.
i feel like he got a lot of concussions right so most likely
you know like he's so stupid yeah that's i'm just thinking
that's why he's so dumb yeah okay it keeps going okay i put
my controller back down no no you should have it for the r1
okay okay my my one finger is on r1 yeah Yeah, good, good.
Who is Khrushchev's lapdog?
Oh, is he beating up the scientists?
He's beating up Sokolov.
Yeah.
Oh, it's so wet.
Oh, okay.
I think he's dead.
Oh, that sounds like a dead body.
I guess he's dead.
No way.
Really?
You gotta make sure you're right.
It's the double tap.
This is like a PSA that nerds aren't welcome.
I hope you'll prove more entertaining than he was.
But first, let's take a look at your body, shall we?
Whoa.
You've certainly seen your share of battles.
It's like actual ASMR.
Close your eyes and just listen to my voice.
Well then, let's get started.
What is your target?
Do I just not open my eyes?
You have a, you have a bandana on.
blindfold yeah yeah or maybe it's the legacy this punch
barely do shit like oh yeah your health yeah bro my help is
so i'm so healthy you're a tough one but even you must have
your limits and i am a wait i'm re-genning because you have
you have a stamina oh yeah it's a bag that's It's a bag over
your head, not a...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I have stamina.
I'm really regaining.
Oh, shit.
This is best up, though.
Oh.
Here's where the fun really begins.
Wait, also, that's been watching me?
Is that what you see?
Yes, he is watching very intently.
Oh, shit.
Now answer me.
how much does the CIA know yeah snake yeah oh they're after
my legacy aren't they your real target is the philosopher's
legacy isn't it philosopher's legacy oh he's gonna tell us
exactly where it's hidden
you know for 10 000 watts how am i still alive oh his heart
oh oh my god did i pee myself that's what i want to see oh
so i just discovered a new kink he's just uh oh
it's no use he's not going to talk he's been trained not to
break that's even worse like when You know, like when he's
peeing himself and then he gets shot because that goes
through his pee-pee I mean, he's already covered in water.
Oh, that is true Yeah, but then it's going straight to the
hole
That's why I'm saying that got hurt that's even more painful
And you're looking for a record of where all that money is
hidden, right?
It's going up the hall!
That that's torture.
In the underground vault of the honeycrap.
Oh, that's... Oh, nice.
Everybody now knows where he actually just...
He's like, you're not gonna talk while I'll tell you.
There's a spy among us.
Also, by the way, the thing that you're...
looking for he's like you know if nobody's gonna tell it me
I'm gonna tell myself who's responsible for this oh not me
not me oh I planted it on him to keep track of his movements
why so the Cobras could ambush him if they knew where he was
gonna be they wouldn't have he's like now i can kill yeah
but it's because he knows cqc boss but under the
circumstances i'm afraid i must ask you to show me some
proof that you and he were not in collusion you don't trust
me is that it not that oh she's lost her men your apprentice
what do you want me to do kill him let's see
Is that why he has an eye patch?
Yeah, baby.
There's nothing more important to a soldier than his eyes.
You made him a soldier.
And now you will unmake him.
Yes.
It'll make for a touching display.
But he looks so badass, though.
He's all yours.
Yeah, but the depth perception.
But she's like, don't do it.
To meet that eye.
Drew and him.
Aw, the cope was.
I missed him.
It died pretty fast.
He has no more Pokemens.
Ooh, this is Elite 4.
Don't underestimate.
Mommy, please.
Mommy, why are you getting near me?
Oh.
Was he listening to, like, a fucking song?
What do you mean?
That's the Kodak.
Oh, that's the Kodak.
Okay, I was going to say it's jamming out right now while
getting tortured.
He has air condition and listening to his favorite song.
He's okay.
What is it, Tanya?
He suffered enough.
Well, well.
Oh.
He knows.
Yeah.
Oh.
He smells mad on her.
That smell.
That smelly smell.
Smelly smell that smells.
Smelly.
You're the spy.
That done.
You're the monster.
Like she's so...
Yeah, that's so suspicious.
I know.
Gay.
Oh, what?
Stop it.
Take attention to her.
He's like, yeah.
Me too.
What?
I want to test her.
Bro, look at her.
He has interest in one thing only.
That's true.
Do
we forget about cutting Snake's eyes out?
There's more pressing matters.
He's got to make everything a show.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
There is no way his entire eye blocked the bullet.
A revolver's bullet.
That should be, like, in his fucking brain.
Come.
We're going to my room.
He's like, I'm all excited now.
Oh, yeah.
He's like, go get into my room.
Oh.
So you survive the colonel's torture, eh?
Oh my god, he's so impressed.
He's so...
Watching this has made me realize something.
I have a torture kink.
It's the ultimate form of expression.
Oh my god, he's so insane.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's a muzzle flash that got the eye.
Okay, I was going to say, there's no way that eyes, those
eyes are made of steel.
You're lucky this time, Tatiana.
Nah, he's just built different.
She's such a good actress.
I mean, that would probably be actually.
You know, actual fear.
Yeah.
There might be a sense of that.
I was going to be like, damn, she's good.
Oh!
Did he...
Oh, I thought it was the dick.
R1.
Oh.
14.75.
144.
Oh, 144.
What the fuck was that?
Was that a ghost?
Hmm.
I've prepared an escape route for us.
Go out and head west.
Pass underneath The connecting passageway.
Yeah, now it's Eva's turn to shoot Snake.
Yeah.
Quiet?
You're quiet!
The sewers are unlocked.
You can use it to get outside the fortress.
I've got your equipment.
Oh my gosh, she's the spy, God.
She's the spy all alone.
He's like, wait, you're Eva.
You're Eva?
Yeah.
Like, why are you helping me?
I'll be in touch No, I can't believe I was Eva the whole
time Oh my god, guys Let's talk to Eva Oh my god, those
glasses, man They're so good Honestly, like the fact that
her hair is like changed In the glasses It is, it is like At
first it's a superman effect Really is Oh, hey, oh, I'm okay
now Okay, oh, I get a four Yeah, now you can eat things
immediately oh like try eat that eat that mouse yeah oh wait
really okay yeah get over here rat how do i eat it did they
clip the fork oh okay yeah what the fuck is there it is and
now just attack it okay get over here don't eat the toilet
okay get over here oh oh there you go i'm yum yum yeah you
don't even have to like hide it in your inventory can i use
my fork to No!
It's okay.
It's fine.
Basically, so there's a transmitter that the one that Ocelot
put in and if you keep it in, you get a special cutscene but
it's okay.
What did I do?
You took it out.
That's okay though.
It's fine.
Oh.
No, I can reload.
Wait, can I?
I think so.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, there you go.
Oh, yeah, I think what.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Or we just watched the entire cutscene again.
I know.
Yeah, yeah.
We just watched.
Okay, okay.
Hey, let me have my gun.
All right.
Eat that.
Eat that gun.
Come on.
Finally.
Yeah.
So there's a couple fun things you can do in here.
Um.
Yeah.
So I don't cure myself, basically, right?
You can cure.
Just don't take out the transmitter.
So you can cure your leg.
Oh, this.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, how do I cure this?
Do I get my fork on it?
Yes.
Oh, I see.
And then just leave the transmitter.
It's a little fun extra thing.
All right.
What do I do here?
Am I stuck here?
You haven't codecked anybody at all this one time.
Oh wait wait, I forgot.
Wait.
What was it?
144.
But also, you can see what the other people say though.
See like what Zero says.
Oh, okay.
Hello.
Papa?
Snake?
Major.
Alright.
right but at least i'm alive that's good enough yeah why did
it give me my radio weapons and equipment from me well don't
worry about your radio and medical items with you yeah i
wonder why that is perhaps falgan's not finished with you
just yet yeah it's my turn to go to his room snake you've
got to escape from that cell somehow there must be a way use
your head all right okay a lot of people in chat are like
trying to backseat you to save the game and quit i'm just
gonna spoil it for you because you know if you want to do it
you can there's like a special special like extra game that
you can do oh what's the extra game it's like it's basically
it's like uh it's it's like uh rising don't worry about it i
can still like am i like delirious or some like why is it
like why would it was a it was a demo for a game that was
going to come out attacking in first person you guys i'm
telling her because if she wants to do it she i want her to
decide if she wants to do it or not all right so all right
it is like an extra thing let's check it out okay how long
is it um it's not super long okay where i should have asked
that Yeah, that's why I wanted to let you know about it.
Because, you know, a lot of people are saying it in chat.
But it is pretty cool.
Did you get cut up?
It feels like someone shoved me under a lawnmower.
Bro, you got fucking electrocuted, like, for five minutes.
I don't.
Snake, have you ever heard of Renfield?
Is that a movie?
It's the name of a character.
He's locked up in a cell waiting for the master to return,
eating the spiders that crawl along the walls.
Change the channel.
Let's change the channel.
Why are you so good at that?
Change the channel.
Paramedic.
I don't like this one.
It's my lady.
Do what you escape by doing for you, my lady?
Hold on, this is the important part.
If you stay there too long, your old buddy Dracula is going
to come and get you too.
Oh no!
are real you better not leave me without someone to talk to
please snake oh she's a nightmare she doesn't want me to die
okay just let me know if you start having nightmares about
dracula
okay now quit the game all right return to main menu okay
now continue it's that's how it should be what the fuck oh
here it is what the
oh oh so a snake is a snake is afraid of vampires and when
he thinks about vampires he has nightmares oh oh is it am i
like my god what's happening Oh my god.
Why is it?
You're like lagging like crazy.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, I'm in a vampire game.
Oh, wait.
You're in a vampire game.
Oh, I had to change the source.
Apparently it's a whole new different thing.
Yeah, it opens up like a new window.
Oh, it's called Night...
Is it Nightmare?
Yeah, because they're having a nightmare.
Oh, that's why I talked about nightmares.
Yeah.
Oh, so they were planning...
Was it supposed to be like a Devil May Cry concept or what?
uh i don't remember the original was like just um one of the
like the the devs if i remember correctly like was working
on this and never came to fruition but then for the remake
they redid the game oh as well yeah and it's platinum that
did it so it's basically yeah bloodborne too yeah it's
literally bloodborne too
it's you that's me oh is that death what's that oh shit that
looks like a silent hill character oh it's kind of yeah like
the little the hippie things the little hip guys oh the ones
that have like no arms usually yeah yeah yeah it looks just
like him yeah yeah can I roll here or no Oh, it's just...
Oh, I can.
Oh, shit.
Oh, combo.
That's fucking right.
Rainbow, combo.
Oh, yeah.
Fuck that fence, though.
Take it out.
Yeah.
What's the point of it anyway?
It's literally just in the way.
Pick that unity-free acid out of here.
I feel like jump.
Yeah, this is a straw.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, can't block this forever.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my, I'm so fucking strong.
I know, it's pretty fun.
All right.
Now where do I go?
I like just being able to slash and hack and slash.
Oh, is that Dracula?
Oh, vampire.
Oh my god.
That's fucking right.
What you gotta do about that?
That's right.
Sunlock you.
Wait.
He ain't so tough.
Where'd he go?
Where did he go?
Yeah, you ain't so tough.
That's like he, right?
Why are you hitting?
There we go.
Easy.
spring to win yeah why is Dracula so weak it's supposed to
be like the king of odds tutorial boss please yeah yeah yeah
it's like yeah you're right tutorial boss oh shit wait wait
spinning's not working guys wait new spin oh shit spin oh oh
oh oh oh oh it's okay I don't have a help bar I wonder if
you can die in this I don't yeah I was like thinking that
yeah you really don't have the health yeah there's like zero
whoa fucking easy oh fuck that tree yeah that's right look
at that one tree in particular that win oh shit wait there's
three draculas now uh because you made fun of them and now
he's embarrassed yeah boom slashy slash slash slash slash
slash slash slash boom hit the buttons press all the buttons
yeah oh my god a little like addition because it was in the
original but then they had to take out the demo for the
master um the HD collection and everything so it's kind of
like oh so it's like a bonus yeah and so now it's like they
just brought it back so yeah people were wondering if it
would be in this again so it's cool yeah that's nice uh like
easter egg yeah oh and then i woke up
snake yeah yeah wake up snake you're having i think what
people really appreciated about it was like you know people
were kind of worried like delta was just like you know not
going to be taken care of and then they saw this and they
were like oh wow wow they made a whole new thing for it yeah
yeah the loading screen is so long holy shit really and you
Like, lag, like, crazy stuff.
Yeah.
They're like, I'm fucking waiting forever for him to
fucking...
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Oh, yeah.
I make sure that flies didn't lay eggs on his, like, in his
arms.
That's what larvae is.
You know, like, if you don't, like, um...
Stitch up the wounds and there's flies there, it'll lay eggs
in it.
Ew!
Yeah.
That's why you gotta put a band-aid on.
Kedokie.
Shut up.
That's true.
That's why you can't have gaping holes, a snake.
I mean, I think there's other reasons why you shouldn't have
gaping holes on you.
I think that does, I guess.
I guess that does.
Oh, call paramedic again.
Time to eat.
Yeah.
So close.
Come on.
Where is he?
yami yami all right all right now the cup oh may i call her
snake what happened what do you think i got a little
nightmare no i'm feeling mommy i had an idea give me a
boo-boo cash there's some more milkies don't say it the last
thing i need is a double feature it was real i was being
attacked by a horde of weird human-like monsters what's
wrong with me what's wrong with me persecution complex
probably triggered by extreme stress oh yeah are you sure
you stretched out a pillow talk whoa i'm sorry snake i
didn't know you were that sensitive to it i mean who'd have
thought no that's his trigger word yeah don't say it don't
say it trigger warning Trigger warning Dracula
Alright Alright and then Oh What's him?
Alright Oh you could call anybody after you went And then
what's it?
1-4-4-75 I had a terrible dream no kidding what happened i
don't want to think about it there was this monster that
looked human at least it was just a dream it's all over when
you wake up oh yeah this is i forgot about this codec
imagine a situation worse than the one you're in now means
life can't be all that bad i sure hope so well let me tell
you about the absolute worst most sickening nightmare i ever
had
What?
What kind of dream is he having?
Oh no!
There isn't a shit!
My old man, John!
everything in that turd's path turned into crap oh it's a
shit tank
holy yes that's a good thing it's a good thing yeah
you see snake people are just turd sacks and then pull them
up with water and it's gotta come out from somewhere okay
okay maybe that was a bad example what what so we're all
always a way yeah we're all crap we're all just yeah we're
all just crap on this world assess the situation you'll find
a way to escape got it don't let my nightmare come true
right all right what was it 144.
all right 75.
all right before i do i actually want to grab some water oh
75.
holy they're so fast all right i know i'm gonna grab some
water real quick i'll be back okay wait why is it 145 oh why
do you go to 145 you made it like that how did i make it
like that i don't know my god do it so slow okay you were
just saying it so fast okay there you go there you go all
right now now you'll get water okay
what about johnny i did think about explaining that to her
but it kind of loses meaning if you don't know the other
johnnies i feel you know what i mean i think this is still
perfectly valid i mean it's like oh totally a perfectly
valid way to get out of the cell so it's also yeah it's also
a lot of work it is i think yeah you you you feel much more
if you're just like oh my gosh it's johnny if you already
know the other johnnies you know so yeah hmm oh yeah she's
definitely gonna kill johnny i think poor guy he's never
stood the chance yeah otherwise it's just a guy and then
he's just like my kid's name is johnny or whatever and
you're like oh you know like it doesn't feel the impact so
that's why i didn't bring it
oh i gotta pee so bad oh hey oh i'm back you gotta pee as
well yeah all right you want to pee me as well i thought you
were getting water oh well i meant like when we watched
snake peed so now oh yeah it's like if i see someone else
pee i have to yeah yeah so you saw snake peed and you're
like oh i guess i gotta pee too you know yeah i've been
holding it in this whole time Do you want me to listen to
this without you or wait for you?
Oh, yeah, you're good.
You're good.
All right, I can... Okay, I'll go listen to it.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah, you'll listen to it.
There it is.
Oh, okay.
I listen.
I'm fine.
I'll be right back.
All right.
Success.
Oh, shit!
What?
Okay, what do I...
What do I...
Okay.
All right.
Pork top.
fork I assume the fork does more damage all right fork okay
all right he's dead I forked him I realize that sounded a
little wrong be careful in your present state you're
practically naked you don't have a single decent weapon and
you'll never survive in a battle take some time and pull
yourself together eva says she's recovered your equipment so
rendezvous with her as soon as possible to get your gear
back use the escape route eva set up for you go down into
the sewers through the manhole northwest section of grozny
okay that's the sewer exiting the holding cells and heading
northwest okay northwest where the fuck is okay i he thinks
i know my directions my cardinal directions that's just
pretty silly but okay so northwest north is up and west is
left but wait is there anything here see okay but like which
is okay oh maybe there's stuff here oh hey there's a little
froggy though all right that's where i was tortured all
right and then uh oh is there oh there's the bath oh there's
stuff under the bed that's good let's see is there actually
stuff under the bed you don't loot here lies oh unless it's
the other bed
god damn it nobody leaves anything here what the oh that's
my transmitter all right we should be good to go all right
me and my trusty fork oh never mind oh oh Nice.
Loots here.
What the fuck?
Tamika Rawson?
Is she real?
Is she...
What?
Oh, the guy has a name?
Oh, what about the other fucking 80 guards I killed?
Oh, you care about Johnny.
Is she real?
Is this like Kojima's like little...
Little shout-outs?
to his folder?
Wait, where do I go?
Okay, this way.
Wait.
Wait, is it this way?
It is.
Oh.
I don't think he sees me.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
I thought I could see you.
You see what I was for!
I really thought I could see you.
I'm sorry.
Alright, so apparently you cannot CQC with forks.
I now know that.
I am now aware.
It's okay.
What are you gonna do?
Oh!
It's okay.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
That's a natural.
That doesn't work.
Oh, okay.
It's okay.
I'll just keep running.
I can run through this.
I can serpentine this.
Oh, shit.
That's okay.
I can keep running.
I made it.
Okay.
Now, where do I go?
Okay, I go left.
Where do I go?
Oh, I go there.
And then, okay, I can...
I'll make it.
Wait, is it?
Is it here?
Oh, my God.
It's over here.
Oh, fuck.
Fuck!
I can still make it!
I can still make it, guys!
They can't shoot forever!
What happened?
You catch CQC with a fork!
Why didn't you tell me that...
Oh my god, I used to rock.
Why didn't you tell me that CQC...
Wait, did you just take out the transmitter?
No, no, no, no.
I got cut.
Okay.
See?
Okay, wait, what?
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
It's a deep cut, too.
Uh, disinfect.
Uh, uh, Sutra, bandage.
Sutra.
Here we go.
She killed Johnny.
I told you guys that she would.
Told you he didn't stand a chance.
Watch this.
What are you doing?
Do you think they know?
Maybe leave?
What are you doing?
I thought...
I'm in the smoke!
There's a dog!
I thought because I'm in the smoke!
I thought because I'm in the smoke.
There you go.
Oh, okay, okay.
What could be in the smoke?
Can't just find me.
I'm in the smoke.
Oh, you can get under the truck.
Oh.
and heal a bit oh how do i i gotta eat my food i gotta eat
my food oh my one vampire bat you have a one bat my one
vampire bat okay um uh what check the map where are you i
think it's that other door over there yeah oh that door wait
how do i i can't cqc anything how do you do anything here
hands.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
Oh, okay.
You're just doing gas.
Go!
You have to go while the gas is... There you go.
But it didn't work!
Why didn't it work?
They can see you once you leave, but you kind of have to
move through the gas.
Okay, have that door over there i'm so fast yeah yeah yeah i
figured it out
okay oh my god oh my god oh my god there's gonna be dogs i
told you to wait and like heal up but you didn't okay okay
okay okay it's okay it's okay it's okay everything thing is
fine yeah just go yeah just go and run just run for it
what's he gonna do shoot me oh my god oh my god yeah to the
right to the right yeah over there oh my god oh my god oh i
don't know if you're gonna make it no no no no turn around
turn around turn around turn around no no no no no where are
you going i don't know turn around oh my god it's that way i
told you turn turn turn straight straight straight straight
straight it's through that gate through that gate right down
to the right yeah yeah yeah yeah crouch crouch down you see
the dogs behind me No, they can't get you anymore.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
It's that hole right there.
It's literally that hole.
I made it.
Oh, not even close guys.
Not even close.
It's so easy.
It was not even close.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I just got down here.
Never punished.
I'm coming to meet you now.
The door at the north actually though.
Let me guess.
There's a problem.
What problem?
I'm alive.
What is it this time?
The Colonel found out you escaped.
He did, huh?
I figured as much.
Yeah.
I wonder how.
I wonder how he figured.
How did he know he got out?
I was so incognito.
Just a couple of dogs found out.
Got to be kidding me.
I'm serious.
And that means the escape.
Raid I laid out is sealed off Eva You had one job
But isn't the exit sealed off You should be able to get out
by heading God I work so hard to get here too You're dead
Okay I would just kind of chill for a second and heal How do
I heal if I don't have food Because you have the stamina
You'll just be hungry for a bit like you just gotta like lay
on the ground i just gotta i mean there's probably rats in
here oh wait there's a lf med oh oh there you go how do i
take that it's in yeah all right oh there we go oh there we
go yay oh yay boy are you well thank you if i do this will i
heal or that just stays still you're healing
we where are the rats no maybe you're not healing yeah i
don't think i am no oh my god that's taking forever oh my
god why don't you have an ounce of patience oh my god did
you not see me run through
did you not see me just ran through the entire russian army
you sat still for two seconds and you were like oh my god
this is like forever oh my god at least five seconds there's
nothing there's gonna be more animals yeah there's nothing
here nothing here i'm just gotta go ahead downstairs
where is there anything here what oh yeah oh there we go
nice yeah i like stockpiled all that instant ramen and they
took it all that's so what the are they gonna do with my
instant ramen eat it probably what do you mean what are they
gonna do it how could they do this to me this is a little
bit of a maze but not really it's not bad it's just um how i
how would i see any oh wait cigar what maybe try another way
yeah it's not helping it's also just draining your health
yeah my tiny little HP
okay well you failed the maze how did I fail the maze why
did there nothing in there
I just okay you got this i i know you got this i guess i
just go straight yeah just keep going oh there's a rat eat
him eat him alive my god get over here i know i hate eating
the tiny animals because they're annoying yeah they're so
they're so hard to hit oh my god please snake please he just
wants he's stinky and he has been why can't you grab this
just go through here that's part of the maze oh is this part
of the maze okay i want i wanted to start the other side you
you it's kind of like a one-way maze oh he's behind it
they're warning you that there's dogs in here oh i thought
oh i can't slash you're trying to eat yeah what did the dog
snake eater not a dog eater all right okay so there's dogs
here then yep there'd be dogs all right there'll be dogs oh
okay the map sort of tells me where to go i guess um so i oh
what how did he get here yeah there's dogs but how did this
dog get here i was right that's That's right.
That's right.
That's freaking right.
That's yeah, that's right.
No, that's right.
Oh shit!
Wait, I ate him.
No, he didn't.
Oh my god.
I'm hungry.
Wait, nothing came out.
Yeah, it disappeared.
You remember what the fork does?
It eats the whole.
I'm no longer hungry.
Oh my god!
I'm so hungry I could eat a dog I did say I was hungry
okay oh my god you got some ammo now at least okay yeah who
needs ammo when I have a fork a fork eat people eat animals
what's the difference don't need that you don't be don't be
selfish
spare him spare a life please but i'm so hungry
i'm so hungry
hey Hey there He's waiting He's waiting to come over And get
eaten You want to hear him coming Did you not hear him
coming?
I thought Oh shit
Oh my god Wait It's not My food meter's not going up You're
not eating them Wait It's just funny to pretend.
I knew I should have ate that rat.
Oh, you should run.
Wait, why?
You not hear the music?
Yeah, but I assume that's like friendly music, right?
Oh, just run.
Am I not running?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, this was in the intro.
Oh my god, this cutscene is great.
It looked more food.
Oh, yeah.
No, stand down, everyone.
Wait, this is a movie reference.
I saw this in the Simpsons.
Yeah, the Simpsons made a parody.
They made a parody of this movie.
on the Simpsons.
I don't know what movie it is, but I saw it on the Simpsons.
Oh my god, he's so excited.
I've been waiting for this.
Oh shit.
Nobody interfere.
Yeah, he's yours.
All yours, baby.
Oh my god.
The bullet!
You'll never get mellows!
This is where it ends.
That's right.
Waited too long.
Stupid face there.
He's like, no foreplay for you.
snake is crazy oh my god i love this part too
it was the next
not yet
that's right they're like what do we do now boss he's slowly
why did you boss we could have shot him boss boss we had him
we had him how were we gonna tell him the commander good
luck toky oh this is a river isn't it this this looks like a
river time to face the consequences of your actions They all
went to heaven!
They...
He's sad.
Are you one of the Cobras?
What did I do wrong?
It was all for democracy!
So sad.
Oh.
A host of sorrows.
You remember there was another member of the Cobras?
There's another member of the co- how many are there oh my
god it literally is six pokemons yeah it's literally six
he's ghost type oh my god he's the ghost type spirit medium
soldier oh he talks the ghosts battle brings death death
brings you probably don't remember because it was last time
they talked about it but there were two people the joy and
the sorrow that were they were like a couple married couple
and the joy is the boss and she had to kill him oh wait make
no mistake the dead oh wait so he is a ghost there's not
spoilers you guys it literally happened they said that in a
codex literally last time of those whose lives you've ended
oh shit Wait, why punish me?
Why not punish your fucking alive wife?
Oh, you were supposed to go undetected, remember?
But, like, was it my fault?
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should have been full HP.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I should have been full HP.
Please tell me I have a gun.
I have 18 bullets.
Okay, I gotta make these 18 bullets count.
I guess.
Oh.
Against a ghost?
Okay.
Wait.
Can I shoot him?
Wait, what?
You could try.
Okay.
This fucker.
Oh my god.
Here comes the horde.
Okay.
It's okay.
I can dodge this.
You're so slow.
Don't.
Don't touch me.
okay how did that hit no oh shit oh i'll die oh my god i
can't i'll die oh my god it's fine it's fine i'm faster oh
my god all right it's okay oh he's not gonna touch me is he
he's not gonna oh my god Okay, wait, where's my gun?
Oh, fuck, I should be diving when he does that.
I just realized.
Okay, every time I shoot him, I have to dive.
All right, threat doesn't need a threat.
Oh my god, they're so slow.
They're not gonna get me.
It's okay.
Okay, everything is fine.
All right, this is fine.
This is fine.
I'll just...
I got the right side.
How the fuck?
Okay.
And then I serpentine.
Oh, he's gonna do it.
He's alting.
He's alting?
There you go.
Yes, I got it.
I figured it out.
I timed it perfectly.
Okay, I need...
to get okay you're getting your body drained by the ghost
okay all right we're almost there there's no more oh no oh
don't remember the first boss you fought it's okay what how
does that hit me i okay oh my god he's right behind me is
okay it's five it's five oh my I got Okay There's a ghost
Okay Apparently I can't Yep I just realized that you cannot
shoot a ghost Alright Ghosts are invincible Yeah we are
Alright Are you fucking kid How?
You have to dodge it I have to How do I?
I can't walk any faster Oh my my god am i guys i'm almost
there right yeah surely i'm almost there oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh it's okay let's hear i'm just a
little
It's so hot.
I thought bam thread the needle Okay All right, I just you
didn't touch me not yet No, he's not.
Nope.
No, he's not.
No, he's not gonna touch me.
No, he's not gonna touch me No, he's gonna get me.
No, he's not gonna get me.
Oh my god The consequences of your actions.
I put them in a better place Oh, God.
Oh, God.
Your health.
It's okay.
I'm faster.
I don't understand.
They're in a better place now.
How is this bad?
I did it for America.
Not for honor.
Oh, God.
Wait, your health.
Wait, your health for real.
Are you going to actually die?
Oh, God.
I'm okay.
All right.
Second boss.
All right, here we go.
Everything is not very...
I don't understand.
Like, how come I can't shoot him?
The ghosts.
Like, it's not me.
oh okay i'll just walk oh no he's not touching me right okay
there you go no no no no no no he didn't touch yeah he did
no no no no no no no no we're fine okay all right more
people incoming oh my god there's so four two more oh my god
lost track how many cobras did i kill them fish god oh my
god i also killed fish too what else okay okay mid um if i
die um does it make me go back from the beginning Mint?
Oh!
There's still hope.
Wait.
Wait, wait, there's still hope.
There actually is still hope.
You're killing them again?
You haven't learned your lesson.
Oh my god.
There's still hope.
Oh my god, there's still hope.
Wait, there's still...
We're figuring it out.
I'd never punish!
As long as Doki can have a gun.
Never punish.
I feel so safe now.
I still...
I never learned my lesson.
This is the spirit of America!
USA.
He really looks like Rambo right now.
You had to just go after them, they're behind you!
These bullets will protect- This one makes me so sad.
Aw, it was the boss.
Look at him, look at Grandpa!
You can't even be bothered!
He's sleeping.
He's just really eepy.
USA USA USA Alright, there's one more Alright, it's okay I
have my bullets to protect me Okay Alright
Okay, oh my god, it's working It actually is working Okay Oh
my god There's screams of freedom.
They're being released.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit.
They're treating me.
They're touching you.
Yeah, it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh, my God.
Not the vultures, too.
The vultures!
I hear you!
You have no more bullets.
Oh, no.
Oh, you're getting sucked.
You're getting sucked.
Oh, no, not the suck Where's my scorpion?
What the what the fuck is the scorpion?
I Don't know it's another gun.
What'd you have?
Oh, it's okay.
Oh My god.
Oh, no Okay, so it's I'm faster
Okay, sorrow Okay, it's fine USA Okay, there you go there
you go
All right, we're fine.
All right, the last one
Okay, this is the plan
This is the plan
One bullet Oh, oh, oh, oh.
There we go.
Just keep going.
Yeah, just keep.
Why do you have to fight?
Why the fuck?
Oh, shit, I'm so.
Oh, it's okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
He deserves that one.
He didn't make it.
All right, here we go.
There we go.
We did it, guys.
Look at that.
Never punished.
You might want to leave.
You might want to get out.
How do I leave?
That's what I'm trying to do.
Look at the body he's over.
Oh, here?
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, wait.
Oh, dude.
Alright.
You can do this.
You can do this, Doki.
Take a look.
Maybe there's something in your items that could help you.
Besides a guide.
Take a look at all your items and your weapons.
Everything that you have.
That equips a different gun.
Check.
Take a look at what items you got, too.
I don't know.
Not just your weapons.
There are other items, too.
My book?
Items.
You're on weapons.
Oh, oh, oh.
Go back.
There you go.
See what else you got.
I did.
What?
I can't even take What's the point?
What
do you think you're doing?
These are the creatures you have killed
You can figure out the rest, Doki
No!
I worked so hard!
I made it so far!
No!
Excellent.
I don't understand!
Why wouldn't my crocodiles scare away the ghosts?
Oh no, it's gonna hit.
Ghosts love crocodiles.
Okay.
You're getting your life sucked.
Oh my god.
This is literally what I do to Ibu, by the way.
freaky ghost
okay okay there you go there you go it's okay okay never
punished never punished are you sure about that never never
punished i'm almost there then what is this then no no it's
just round two round two
all right I go to the left to the left to the left to the
left to the left
that's fine he's not there you go oh my god he took half my
HP he took half my HP oh my god okay it's okay he doesn't
know he doesn't know how to go backwards he doesn't know how
to go backwards no it's fine okay doesn't know how to aim
either we're okay all right all i have to do i bait them to
the left and then i go right that's all i have to do and
then i slowly very slowly go right side because they will
not expect the right side oh my god they're so close to me
Oh my god.
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
Everything's fine.
Okay.
That's not going to hit me, right?
No!
Oh, God.
Get out!
Oh, no.
This is where I've lost more than the other times I've been
here.
Oh, no.
Why is he invulnerable?
She's a ghost.
Oh my god, no.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Just four more.
Oh god, please don't hit me.
Four more.
Or just four more.
It's just four more.
Okay.
Yeah, you got this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is fine.
It's fine.
Now I just gotta grab my other gun.
No, I just gotta, you know what?
I have an idea Oh surely All right, maybe this the shotgun.
Why would that change the shotgun would be stronger Like oh
my god every time he fucking There see I'm worthless now
okay maybe shotgun was not it it's okay i still have this
you're hitting with bullets of sadness and self-doubt all
right come on second boss oh my god i did it i dodged it i
dodged it oh this is not looking so good for me oh my god i
actually started smoking you're so stressed you started
smoking Come on, let's take Think of your health Oh my god,
no Take this Oh no I might need to do a third attempt Take
that Ha He's doing a little somersault He doesn't know Why
is the fear such a freak?
Why was he doing that for?
Oh my god Oh my god dodge are you fucking getting me oh no
oh oh oh oh oh he's on your booty oh oh oh he didn't grip me
though he was trying to grab it what do you think you're
doing shooting yeah what do you think
great question oh no
no there's still so many more
There I was there There's no way I killed that many people
They're like over exaggerating There's no way I there's no
way That many people Actually I feel like there's There
should be more No There's no There's no way I killed that
many people guys I wonder if the fire counts yeah that
shouldn't count if they fall off the cliff that's on them
that's on them yeah yeah exactly oh this is not good this is
not good why the fuck can I my bullets not go through him
maybe one day she'll understand what a ghost is you guys
haha
What?
There's no fucking way!
It's kind of bullshit sometimes, I'll be honest.
No, it's 100% bullshit.
Oh my god, no, this is not the run.
This is definitely...
Since you said that, this is not the run.
This is not the run right now.
What are you talking about?
You got this.
No, this is definitely not the run.
It's the run.
No, no.
You did it first try.
I have so little HP.
I have so little HP!
No, I believe, I believe.
Wait, what does the dive button do?
It makes you so you can swim.
Should I be swimming?
Look at me, look at him.
Oh, I think he just hurt you.
Oh, grandpa.
I don't know if swimming is dive.
Like, what does dive even benefit me for?
like but how does it benefit me i don't understand oh
grandpa grandpa grandpa oh no okay maybe maybe this gun will
do something i'm thinking the guns don't do anything it's my
hypothesis he's like the gun makes you drown oh yeah no
oh okay not this i was not planning on shooting him but okay
this is really bad this is actually you're just like oh god
why you walk right into them dokey i there's nothing i could
do they were all blocked i killed too many they're they're
literally blocking the entire fucking river what do you want
me to do like look at
Like, look at this!
Yeah, no, it's over.
Oh my god, it's over.
It's over.
Goodbye, everyone.
Oh my god, wait, wait, what if?
Oh, it's over.
It's over.
Wait, I'm less!
Oh
Never punished never you know, I don't regret it.
I don't regret killing all these people Don't be sad We'll
meet again someday.
Oh Oh shit Oh, that's when his wife shot him.
Holy shit, don't these brains work.
I think you put the aha soup up.
Nice.
You've just been in the water.
water that entire time just drowning away casually drowning
you know maybe you know a couple more brain cells have died
from suffocation but that's all right it's possible for him
there's nothing left it's just pure instinct now oh i had a
butterfly oh oh there's the ghost yeah
The sorrow.
Snake, are you all right?
That was a close call.
What the hell happened to me?
You were halfway drowned at the bottom of the river.
Almost crossed over to the other side.
Other side.
That's right.
Never punished.
That means I can kill more because there's no punishment.
Yeah, there's no punishment no more.
What kind of man was he?
He survived the river.
I survived so
good job you managed to avoid drowning someone who can
communicate with the spirit world and evoke the spirits of
the dead in other words he could talk to ghosts in the end i
learned that i could finally kill again what about him and
the boss what was the story between them i don't know the
details why don't we ask sigand all right i finished
checking up on this sorrow guy a while ago i thought you
guys already knew though knew what that he's dead he's been
dead for two years now he died two years ago i just talked
to you know those clips you were at and the boss is the one
the boss two years ago the boss was sent by the cia on a
secret mission to seleno yarsk that's when she met the
sorrow who'd gone back to the soviet union after the cobras
broke up at the end of the war except this time they were
enemies and then what what happened the sorrow herself and
accomplished her mission at least that's what the records
say he is dead he was never there in the first place he just
couldn't ignore the boss oh he was like in love yeah it
looks like it's not time for me to die he hasn't moved on
otherwise the whole mission is We're counting on you, pal.
Roger that.
They said this in a...
I didn't spoil nothing.
They literally said this in a codec last time.
I remember.
Yeah.
I took a pretty freaky detour.
What are you talking about?
Nothing.
Forget it.
Let's just say I'm back.
But how did you escape from the sewers?
I jumped in the river.
They were just reiterating it.
Yeah, you can't actually lead Metal Gear Solid YouTuber.
I mean, if you ended up in the river, then I know a good
spot nearby.
Let's meet up there.
Where is it?
Keep going upstream until you get to a waterfall.
A waterfall, huh?
Rage bait's successful.
The cave behind a waterfall upstream.
Impossible to rage bait me.
Shee.
It's impossible.
I'm always kidding.
yeah she's just doing it for content guys when she's yeah
guys don't you want the reaction yeah it's just how the do i
go up oh yeah it's in caution so be careful they know you're
around oh i oh i still have my gun wait do i have my other
gun no
how do i go up
Oh.
There's a shop.
Yeah, I never have crashed out once.
Yep, not even yesterday or today.
What happened yesterday?
I don't know.
You were with Matara.
That was the day before yesterday.
Oh, the day before yesterday.
Oh, there he is.
Get that guy.
Kill him.
no no punishment oh yikes
you think he knows oh did you see that guy sit down or lay
down did you see him no okay there's a no i saw i saw him
lay it down all right wait where do i have to go now guys
wait until she gets to the river part two
Oh There's a guy up there.
Yeah Yeah What what what what the guy who laid down the guy
who laid down yeah the guy who laid down saw you
It's fine.
There's only a couple guys there he is that's the guy who
laid down earlier Bro, okay that this gun fucking sucks.
Don't you dare I'm sorry you just don't know how to use No,
no, this gun fucking sucks.
You just don't know how to use it.
How is that not?
Okay, there you go.
That's a headshot.
There you go.
That's the best weapon in the history of all weapons.
Alright, alright.
You have your fucking red glasses on.
You're looking through your shipping glasses right now.
My shipping glasses.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're looking through your Fujo glasses.
Calm down.
I think it's just a skill issue.
You're nearly there.
there by the way yeah but i want to grab some app oh who
cares yeah you're about to get your stuff yeah all right i'm
swimming i don't think you can swim through the waterfall oh
i have to go around all right nice yuppie yeah
now you'll get the the extra scene that happens when you
have the transmitter oh are one oh my yaoi scene no oh quite
yeah my my heated rivalry
oh shaziva
she's so cool does that mean you're feeling it the ship are
you feeling are you yeah i understood um part one i know i
know you did in part one but like it gets better it gets
better and better like it really just like marinates and
you're like oh my god it truly is the slowest burn though
here's your equipment uh you could use a towel so could you
i see you could use a towel oh why is it red because of the
vampire oh yeah I was because it's because I'm locked in a
Russian prison Oh shit, I'm hungry He's finally eating some
cooked food Oh my god, finally it's now longer Rob Also,
you'll want to R1 for this Oh my gosh, she's not wearing
pants Oh my god, I could tell Whoa Whoa Whoa Whoa Whoa Whoa
Whoa.
She's all legs.
Didn't you have to eat them at the KGB?
In my training, we always got the good stuff, French,
Italian.
That kind of thing.
A regular Matahari.
Oh, wow.
What you could do is call me Cynthia.
That's your name?
Tell me something.
How does it feel to spy on your own country?
Oh, that's her American name, her chosen name.
my job can't even eat a snake during a mission huh i don't
think so wait but why call her cynthia whoa oh you will wow
oh my oh my god so the way he just gulped me yeah he's like
woman what do you want to eat let's see how about sushi did
she really need to cry like that She's showing her prowess.
Yeah, I was like, meow.
She's like, I'm a cougar on the hunt.
He's like, he's so stupid.
This is my e-pal that I hired to be with me.
Because she's my rinked girlfriend.
Oh, it's depth perception.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Boobs.
Thank you, Snake.
I'll be your eyes from now on.
Eva.
She wants him so bad.
R1.
Guys, I'm pressing R1 and there's no close-ups.
Sometimes there are hidden R1s, though.
Yeah.
Oh, he's like no reaction.
No reaction.
Ouch.
Don't touch his open wounds.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Bro, is he even kissing back?
I can't tell.
Oh, I'm actually...
She's definitely doing a lot of the work.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I think he's the starfish.
Starfish?
Okay, I'm not slaying.
What is that?
Yeah, you ain't a bro.
You ain't a bro.
Oh, here it is.
Here's the extra scene.
What?
Oh, wait, I thought this scene would be with Asana.
No, I told you.
It's not, but...
Oh, oh my...
When did it get like that?
Let me do it.
Oh, it's Austin Powers.
Oh, I've been trying to do this kind of thing myself.
Just relax and let me handle it.
It's a restituber.
Yeah, I mean...
This is WrestleTube for 2026, guys.
We're getting it.
We got it.
What the fuck?
Holy shit, he stepped on her boss.
Oh, my god.
There, a transmitter.
Is that how they do it in the KGB?
Sometimes.
Would you rather I did it American style?
CBT.
Shut up.
Oh my god.
Yay, you got your stuff back.
On my clothes.
Oh my god, my eye patch!
Yeah, it looks so good.
That's the Metal Gear reference.
Yeah.
A highly proved explosive from the west.
molded into any shape like clay with just this much you
could blow up the shagohad and the lab along with it is that
right yeah but there's a trick to using it tell me about it
oh my guys she molding them that's a waste of material what
do you think oh my she used half of the material no it's
still good
he's like hey heart okay anyway tell me tell me the briefing
Easter unit uses liquid fuel the fuel tanks are in the main
wing of the weapons lab in the hangar housing the Shagohat
itself so I should blow up the tanks that's the basic idea
it should be enough to blow up the entire hangar what man
that's some strong-ass shit in order to destroy the hangar
you'll have to set explosives on each of those tanks all
four of them it should be no sweat for you oh this part's
not that bad okay the hangar is completely deserted not
quite they've still got guards posted there so what do i do
after i set the c3 the bombs run off the top also that's a
lie there are definitely guys in there oh yeah okay oh my
actually time 20 minutes oh okay 20 That's fine.
Uh, yeah.
20 minutes, that's fine.
I can do this in 20 minutes.
Yeah.
That's the mission I was given.
By CruzeGen?
America doesn't have any use for it, does it?
But I haven't forgotten my other mission either.
Wait, she has the lipstick.
Wait.
Was she poisoning me?
She would have to poison herself too.
As long as she doesn't lick her lips is fine.
Okay, well you have to go back to Grozny Graz.
Go back to Grozny Graz.
Go to Grozny Graz.
When you entered the main wing from the second floor of the
east wing, yeah, that's the entrance to the the Shagohod's
hangar.
Use this key to open that door.
The door right when I enter the main wing.
Got it.
What about you?
I'll get things ready for our escape.
She's her getaway driving.
Yep.
I'm going to set a bomb there, so I'm taking half of the C3
with me.
Right.
I'll set off the weapons lab then.
She's so hot.
And watch out for Ocelot.
He suspects you're not who you say you are.
Sorry, the colonel still trusts me.
Snake thinking about Oshawa.
Yeah, he's always thinking about him.
Jesus.
She only wants him more.
She's so hard to get.
I know.
He's like, the one man, the hot cat.
He doesn't want me.
Yeah.
If I didn't ride the deer, I could go on living.
What?
When I'm riding, the wind hits you.
me so hard that it hurts that pain keeps my mind off the
pain of having to be someone else it's not easy always
fooling myself like this gosh she's such a good actress i
know she's like ashley method acting i only get off my bike
when i fall in love oh oh Oh.
Tatiana.
Your real name.
Eva.
What's wrong with Tanya?
Okay, Tanya.
Oh.
It's a button camera.
R1.
Oh.
What did you do that for?
So fast.
Wow.
You're gonna get wet.
He's like, curse me.
How did you get wet?
I know.
I saw it's gonna be like, you smell like a waterfall.
The last time we saw Snakey headed towards the waterfall.
Alright, now.
Very suspicious.
That's pretty sus.
Wait.
Actually, now.
This one.
And then...
Oh.
Oh my god, the glasses are so stupid.
all right let's grab that and then let's grab all her guns
stupid gun no shut up it's amazing gun you just don't know
how to use it oh yeah sure did you know how to use it i
didn't use it only only he can use it
all right and then we got it Wait, where's my fucking
crocodile hat?
Gotta equip it.
Oh, and it's the one-eyed version.
It's perfect now.
Wait, do I have my glasses on while...
Yes.
Wait, does the crocodile also have one hat?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
It's cute.
Alright, off we go.
Matties.
Yay.
There's a bunch of items.
in this area so just like yeah run around and there's no
guys just grab everything is that frog yeah you can get some
more food too yeah oh wait did i oh i didn't equip oh wait i
don't need to equip my well you probably want to have things
yeah i have to say oh wait i'm full hp yeah oh a tree frog
yeah your fps view is now one-eyed too yeah yeah is it Oh.
Maybe when you're shooting, though.
When I'm shooting?
Alright, let's see.
Maybe.
Nope.
It's fine.
Yeah.
Nothing wrong.
Oh, maybe you didn't know everything.
No.
Look again.
Oh, looks like you're wrong.
See how it's darker on the one side?
It's hard to tell because you're in the tunnel.
Oh.
Nope.
Don't know where you're trying to go.
Don't know what you're talking about.
She's blind.
Nope.
I think you're just making shit up.
She's trying to rage bait me, but it never works.
Let's grab this.
Big thing.
Oh wait, there's another frog.
Grab them.
A tree frog.
there you go nice all right now we should have everything
yeah they give you a bunch of stuff going back oh nice all
right back to gross nigrad gross nigra back where we started
that's not where we started back to where we all began this
is this is where the first metal gear game ever happened
rosny grud
you really don't have that much to go there's like a bit but
like also not at the same time okay it's a lot of cut scene
too that will all right go through so it's just movie time
not quite you still have gameplay but like i'd say at this
point the the bombs yeah i'd say at this point it's like
almost half cut scene half gameplay all right
Good thing you made it up.
We're over there.
That's the...
That's the Tesla.
What's it?
Oh, the cyber truck.
That's the cyber truck right there.
Oh my god, Kojumbo, you did it again.
You predicted the cyber truck.
Alrighty.
You know how to get back to that area.
You did it once.
it again yeah it happens so fast but i sure do i will tell
you though in the area of the lockers there's an important
outfit you would want to get in there the lockers where the
fuck is the lockers remember where you put rykov oh oh my
god what the okay wait i got to watch out there's a lot of
guys watch this oh
my god it almost where are you going is it not here Oh
You just you just have to go through another area now
basically okay, wait I can it's okay.
It's okay.
I can I can watch watch this
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah
Perfect execution good job boss all right and then all we
have to do watch this
um i don't think that oh that got you and oh oh oh it's okay
watch this don't forget your oh do you have a suppressor for
that no okay you don't need a suppressor okay
oh where am i you you remember how to get there yeah yeah
you're gonna Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I do.
Yeah, yeah.
Go, go, go.
Oh, what the fuck?
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, my gosh.
It's literally right there.
Oh, it's literally right there.
Yeah, but what happens when you get inside?
Oh, we'll figure that out.
Okay.
Oh, God, okay.
Okay, I got an idea.
Got an idea That's the subject
Alright time to go upstairs Oh You think he saw me?
Those are the scientists They don't care They don't matter
They don't do anything They just scream And they They're
little weasels They rat you out Okay That's fine I'm curious
about Alright Alright Alright Now we start stealthy Yeah
Yeah Now that I'm inside a house, I feel more safe.
Now that I'm inside, I feel much more safe.
See, look.
Everything is fine.
Everything is awesome.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Did you not see the guy coming?
I see him.
No, I saw him too.
I saw him.
It's okay.
Nobody saw anything anymore.
Oh.
I believe in you.
Oh, it's okay.
Nobody knows.
Everything is fine.
And then I eat.
All right.
Now we start stealthing.
I've had enough.
Right here.
Feed on a tree frog.
This is where we start stealthing.
Those guys literally don't matter.
They're just screaming at you out.
Oh fuck, what the fuck?
Okay, there we go.
See, everything's fine.
Everything is awesome!
See, look, everything is okay.
And then we just...
We start stealthing right here.
Oh, there's a guy coming?
Yeah, but he doesn't know.
knows why didn't you seek you see him he was right there it
the prop didn't show up how do you seek you see when the
prop doesn't show up with your hands oh my hands you pass
the oh just kidding you're good oh no no no you're good
you're good yeah yeah go straight go straight go straight
okay you were going the right way it was me it was me oh
that's right the door doesn't open remember oh wait wait
wait go now go now go now oh my god oh shoot you could oh
yeah you could I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it.
Wait, where did he go?
Okay, there you go, there you go, there you go, there you
go.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine,
we're fine.
And now, now self starts here.
Oh, that's, oh, that's not good.
That's, oh, right now.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, that's, oh.
All right.
And then...
Okay, where is...
Okay.
This locker.
This one?
Oh, oh, and now...
Oh, no.
Just kidding.
No, it's not that one, but...
That one's still good.
You could hide in there.
Wait, yeah.
Yeah.
Now, now we start to sell.
Oh.
Everything's good.
Yep.
Oh.
Just a nerd and a locker.
Wait, if the nerds see me, will they alert?
They scream, yeah.
They're really annoying because they just go, Oh, and they
alert everybody.
Why are you doing that?
They're going to hear you.
You're going to wait the full 80 minutes or 80 seconds.
Let's just leave.
Okay, well, okay.
Yeah, we can do it without it.
Wait, do what?
No, well, you have to put the bombs on the thing.
You just go and do things so quickly.
Oh.
But when you said...
When you said it's not that locker, I just...
Oh, okay, I guess none of the locker.
What do you mean?
None of the locker!
I just thought, oh, I guess that means it's none of the
lockers.
If it's none of the lockers.
You can go back.
You can get it.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
It's just, it just makes this a whole lot easier.
Agreed.
That leaves just one more mission for you to carry out.
The boss.
Aww.
For now, just focus on destroying the Shagga Hood.
Yes, sir.
I'll let Sigint fill you in on how to destroy it.
Yeah, how do I do the thing?
Like Eva was saying, if you're looking to blow the whole
place sky high, the best way is to take out those liquid
fuel tanks with the C3.
You know there's four tanks in there, right?
You have to put C3 on all four of them.
To plan a C3 charge, all you gotta do is equip the C3 and
press the attack button while standing near a tank.
Just like TNT.
Ooh, it's that easy.
But make sure you don't plant it in the wrong place.
You barely got enough C3 as it is.
right good point i'll make sure not to plant it anywhere
else could man and be careful liquid fuel has a nasty habit
of going off at the slightest shock so don't go using any
heavy firepower near the tanks unless you're aiming to get
yourself barbecue i'll keep that in mind that doesn't sound
fun the c3 charges all have to go off at once if you want to
bring down the hanger in one fell swoop so if i were you i'd
wait until after you plant the last charge to start the
timer planting all four charges before I start the timer
okay yeah 20 minutes that's easy make sure you get your ass
out of that place by yeah I just had to run fast all I've
got the rest is up to you good luck pal all right I plant
all four bombs and then and then I do the charge I can
listen
listen you guys i can i can process information wait which
locker is it uh figure it out this locker is it this locker
oh there's food there's a passion oh is it this one is it
this one oh it's nothing or what about this one god damn it
which fucking locker is it figure it out oh is this one oh
uniform that's the one so basically there's you know how
they were like oh yeah there's guards there's guards manning
it no not the sneaking one oh makes this yeah so they say
there's not there's guards but there's also janitor guys
that that act just like the scientists so yeah, like they'll
recognize you or they'll be they'll they'll notice you if
you get too close to them they'll be like, huh, that's not
that's not one of our men, but the guards, they don't notice
at all.
So you're okay.
So I can wear this right?
Yep.
Look at his ass and it too.
It's so good.
Oh, that's why you wouldn't.
Oh,
yeah, yeah, they're the janitors.
Look at this.
Oh, I mean, they're like specially molded.
It's like so...
Don't have lots of experience with this, doing this with
rivals.
Wow.
All right, go on in.
Am I okay with the crocodile hat?
Oh, sure.
Yeah.
I hadn't...
That...
That was not very confident.
Oh, wait, he's so close.
Wait, can I make him to go sleep?
Yeah, you can.
oh i can't you can no i don't have i can't use my gun can i
see if you see him you try uh you there are other ways okay
all right you have other you have other things you have
other wait i do yeah check your backpack remember cigarette
gas look at all the things that say z z z oh oh
the handkerchief you know all the things that say is easy on
it wait how do i do this um noise
just wiping wipe wipe wipe wipe you got a little thing on
your nose honey let me get that we cannot burn him
No, that I don't know.
Aww.
Nah.
No, this is a fork.
You don't have the torch equipped.
Oh, you're right.
Where's my torch at?
This doesn't work, so...
Torch time.
Torch, I'm torch.
Oh, oh, wait, no, that's still the...
Oh, oh, wait, no.
Wait, where's the torch?
Oh, oh, oh.
Ah, Lane.
Unlucky.
If I do this in front of someone, they'll call me out,
right?
Uh, probably.
Okay, but like, how would they know?
But you can run, like, that guard right there, you can run
past him, but all the maintenance guys, they'll be like...
Huh?
They'll notice you, too, from far away.
Oh, really?
Yeah, they're sneaky.
These guys hate them.
Oh.
Okay, I didn't know.
He's gonna notice.
get out of there don't forget to plant the c3 wait where's
the c where where is the fucking thing i don't remember okay
it looked like a square you'll see him oh oh yeah don't let
that guy see hey yeah he a bad man yeah
okay oh there it is so if i plant it on this thing the guard
See, they're so annoying.
I hate that they're such rats.
They're like little they're like damn rats Yeah, they're
like oh, I don't recognize this guy.
Oh, yeah, yeah You recognize every fucking jatter just
because I didn't go to the office party, huh?
I know they're so Look at him like pretending to do work.
He's moving at a snail's pace.
Wait, um, where's my c4?
Oh, oh I need to equip my c4
c3 oh c3 all right if i plant it on there will they notice
it they don't notice it but they will notice you planting it
so you have to do it when nobody's around oh okay even the
guards yes so can i plant it on the side uh i usually plant
it where that guy is literally standing okay if i have it
out in my hand will they notice it around with c3 let me try
let me try i'll just run around oh my god how is he still
looking there's another one down down the ramp to the right
yeah wait i think he's going okay he's leaving finally what
were you oh yeah you see you could place it you could place
it yeah there you go there you go okay cool now i'll get to
the other one
Hello.
Nice.
Got a car.
Yeah?
I finished planting the bomb on the rail bridge.
If we get rid of the bridge, the enemy won't be able to
follow us.
That should at least buy us some time.
I've also set up the escape route.
Oh, okay.
Everything's good.
I just finished planting the second charge.
Give me a little more time.
Okay.
I'll be waiting for you at the bridge.
All right.
Very loud.
and conspicuous beeping yeah don't worry about it don't
worry about it just me doing my job there you go there but
watch out for that guy right next to you oh you can go on
the other side i was just gonna plant it you know i mean you
could do that too i think you'll know that oh he doesn't
he's not looking yeah do it
this part's pretty easy i'm not gonna lie it's pretty fun
though because from this side like yeah stupid idiot oh my
god oh my god oh my god you can just run past him and like
plant it oh there you go boom easy bomb has been planned to
see guys eventually i stealthed
the maintenance out there.
What is that beeping over there?
He's like screw your heart.
I'm gonna make it into my own thing.
What is he making?
Is that bullet?
Oh, he's fucking butterfly?
Yeah, because he couldn't grab it before.
Oh
Okay, he grabbed it now.
Oh Nice reflex bro
Nice.
Hey, guys.
Do you guys hear pee-pee?
That definitely wasn't there to her.
I'm on my way out now.
What a funny prank, guys.
Plenty fake.
Pretty fake C3s on these.
Yeah, she can handle it.
All right, then.
We'll hurry up and get out of there.
All right.
Oh, man.
Oh, CQC.
CQC?
What?
Now he gets to walk around with his gun.
Oh.
Eva!
Wait, I thought she was ready!
Uh-oh.
Hey, remember me?
Oh, shit, boss!
Mommy.
Mom?
Why'd you come back?
Valid question.
Oh, shit.
Oh, snake.
You should have...
Oh.
Damn, he breakdancing.
Ooh, the tension.
It does look like a squid game outfit.
That's true.
Oh, R1.
I saw it.
You see
it in that one frame?
Yep, I saw our eyes.
Yeah, we had a wide frame.
This woman was found snooping around my underground vault.
When she was captured, look what we found on her.
Did you see it?
The Philosopher's Legacy.
Oh my god, the Philosopher's Legacy!
Oh, it was like like the in the Bollywood cut, like cuts.
I won, I won, I won, I won!
Yeah, remember that 20 minutes?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bro, he looked like...
What's his name?
The guy who does, like, Avengers Cat, like, the Marvel
cameos.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
It was gasoline.
Motorcycle gasoline.
Yeah, he looked like Stan Lee for a second.
To think that lovely Tatiana was a spy.
The guy who does the Marvel cameos.
It was not like he was the guy who fucking like...
He was the guy that does the marble can of use?
Such a fine woman she was.
Damn.
What about Radcliffe?
Radcliffe.
What?
He's gonna be...
Raikoff!
Yeah.
He's done.
That's it.
What?
he doesn't show up anymore yes she was an obedient one oh
she was my precious little oh my god oh isn't that right my
poor princess oh what was that do you have something to say
to me oh it's the kiss of death yeah oh oh no No.
So close.
Maybe you shouldn't have said anything.
Maybe she shouldn't have said that.
Like...
I've had enough kisses from you.
Oh!
Jesus.
It's like my favorite line in this whole game.
That's your favorite.
Oh, shit.
Sadly.
something so beautiful yeah the timer is still going even
during the cutscene isn't that so funny like you don't have
20 minutes you have oh no explain it before i kill you i've
had enough kisses during the last great war oh my god all
right i put my controller down i'm getting a history lesson
now the pact was a blueprint for defeating the axis powers
and creating a new world order to secure victory in the war
the three countries pooled their resources to conduct the
most covert types of operations and research the atomic bomb
rocket technology the Cobra unit one might not be and they
amassed an enormous sum of money to fund these money money
they're explaining the war philosopher's legacy though
uh-huh man that wealth is the philosopher's legacy hey baby
after the war was the three countries were to divide the
Philosopher's Legacy amongst themselves.
This explains why the United States and the Soviet Union
were able to steal away the best scientific minds in Germany
as soon as the war ended.
But our great motherland has far surpassed its pathetic
rivals.
We possess enormous wealth, the most advanced technology,
and overwhelming power, assets fitting of our great country.
My father was one of the men in charge of managing the
Philosopher's Legacy.
In the confusion that ensued after the war ended, he devised
a series of ingenious plots to ensure that the Soviet Union
would have total control over the legacy.
The money was divided up and laundered through banks all
over the world.
Switzerland, Austria, and Hong Kong.
Oh, God!
Thank you, Kojumbo.
After my father's death, I learned of this secret and
obtained the microfilm.
With this money and the support of Brezhnev and his allies,
I built this fortress of Grosnygrad and Granin's research
facility.
But that worthless fool Granin failed to produce results.
to build mechos dog sokolov and his invention the shagohad
my physician and grew made it too troublesome to attack
sokolov's facility directly but the spy network established
by the secret pack still existed i used it to contact the
boss yeah the boss was conniving enough to see things my
Wait, was that the... Is that the boss?
Yeah, that's the boss.
Look at the eyes!
Look at the cutie!
The cripple!
We will use the legacy to heal that rift and make the world
whole again.
To do this, we need strength, an unstoppable trump card with
enough power to bring order to the world.
That trump card was to be the Shagohod and the Cobra Unit.
Do you really?
I still have the Shagohod and the legacy.
There is nothing America can do to stop us.
Boss, take this someplace safe.
Ooh, you trust her, then.
Yeah.
She's gonna, oh, she, he, oh, that was a test.
She's like, come on.
Come on.
It's just right there.
I have my own Philosopher's Legacy.
Yeah, what is it?
It's in my Metal Gear cabinet.
Oh, like a replica?
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, still 10 minutes, by the way.
I wonder how many minutes you have left now.
I don't know if there are any surprises waiting for us.
I'll dispose of her as well.
dispose of her leave everything to me oh that double agent
the double double agent double double agent i wonder if
there's a triple agent wait so like she let her crew die I
Did the crew know did the crew know No, she's she's she's
doing what she's got to do
It was a test for them also They just weren't good enough
They just didn't they didn't read the memo They didn't read
the script this moment twice now oh yeah he's got to do it
again he's gonna do it oh oh yeah okay all right 10 more
minutes of flipping what the are you gonna do no more field
strips
oh okay well okay five more the timer is still going by the
way What the fuck?
He just sheaves them?
At least shoot it once.
Enough of this.
Oh.
He took the gloves off.
The gloves are off.
The bare hands.
You will stand right there and watch.
Got it?
This is revenge for Island.
Look, you had plenty of time, Oslo.
That's on you.
He gave you so much to...
time
oh my god it's a mecha second standoff oh
so that's what he can do to bullets wait what what did he
did he like just took oh r1 r1 where's my timer where's my
time oh my god it's the time where's my time Stanley!
We're...
Let's get started, shall we?
Where did he go?
Everybody's...
Because it didn't say Mexican standoff.
This is a once-in-a-lifetime battle.
We're so high.
It would be too high.
My god.
Wait, what?
What is he wearing?
Is that a football uniform?
This is a 1Z.
Oh, this is a 1Z.
Bro, it looks like he's playing rugby.
It looks like a fucking rugby uniform.
Wait.
It's just you and me now.
All right.
R1?
Oh my god, there he is, sadly.
Six minutes left.
Out of 20, you had 20 minutes.
They gave you six.
He loves him.
Look at this.
He helps him out.
Oh my god, I'm ready for...
I don't think I can CQC this guy.
All right.
Actually, that's like what you have to do.
Okay, I...
Bro, bro, he has so much...
Okay.
You're mine, son of the boss.
Oh, that's my code, dude.
Oh.
Alright, good luck.
Five minutes.
Oh, I should take this off.
Yeah, yeah, you should take it.
I should.
I should take it off.
i would even put on like i mean you could put on like the
battle dress you'll take less damage or this mm-hmm okay oh
shit i'm packed up right now oh my god i have every type of
bulletproof right now i'm like yeah there you go wait
gotta dodge oh
okay okay i i was curious but now i know i how do i i love
how ocelot has a has a of health oh i figured it out i
figured it out yeah oh my god oh my god where's i forgot to
equip the cqc okay shit okay yeah yeah okay Oh my god, oh my
god, I'm sorry, oh shit!
Ow!
Get up!
He's just laughing, he's just standing, get up!
I'm trying!
Oh, nice roll, nice dodge.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh, fuck, oh, fuck, okay, okay, give me a sec, I'm just,
I'm...
Okay, um, do I not...
Am I not CQCing?
You gotta just kick him, you just kick him.
What the...
to kick him yeah like just punch and kick him punch and kick
him and not shoot okay okay okay give me a sec get my knife
in there is a way to cqc like okay don't you remember the
basics come on doggy okay god if i like the whole game wait
why did you equip the knife we can't equip the gun we both
allow cqc oh oh guys you guys remember the basics it's oh my
god It's pretty bad.
It's pretty...
CKZ!
No!
Oh shit!
She doesn't remember the first thing!
Yeah!
Okay, now shoot him, shoot him, shoot him!
Or do whatever, kill him!
Yeah, no, I mean...
Well, I think shooting him would be more effective.
Don't lay next to him!
Wait, you should have totally got into picture mode.
That would have been so good.
Wait, I understand now.
stand i understand now oh geez secrecy okay okay and then
and then wait wait wait i get it watch this
no wait what are you doing
oh in the booty i told you i told you i understand you might
want to cure though because oh yeah yeah no i'm pretty
fucked up right now it took me a while but i get it now You
got it, you got it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It took me a while.
Nice.
Oh.
Oh, whoops.
Um.
A booty shot.
Booty shot.
A thickly area.
Not yet.
Okay, I need a split.
And then, oh shit.
Bandage.
Whoops.
Am I hungry?
I am hungry.
Give me a second.
He'll let me eat a little bit before I...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're eating a Russian meal.
Like, of course you would let me eat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's fine.
Just a tree from...
Just a little rat as a snack.
Whoa!
See, I understand now.
CQC!
That shot got him!
Every time in the butt.
Okay.
It works!
Make sure you... I love Ocelot being like, keep it up.
He's encouraging you.
Yeah, yeah, he's a homie.
It's so cute.
He's actually a homie right now.
What's he doing?
He's...
He's shooting you.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
This doesn't really work, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What is he doing?
He's recharging.
Oh, that's how he recharged?
Quiet, Ocelot.
That's on him.
Boom.
Oh, three now!
Hey, CKC!
Okay, there we go.
Wow.
It's that easy.
Phase two.
Okay, I do not have a lot of time left.
So, oh.
He's not even watching.
He's angry.
Oh, he's angry.
No talking.
He no talking.
Sorry, Colonel.
I'm afraid I can't do that.
What do you mean, you can't?
I made a promise to the boss.
Who the boss?
What did she ask for?
I am your commanding officer.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah, he shot every...
Okay, yeah.
Alright.
So funny.
Oh, he used up too much energy.
Are you questioning my authority?
My authority?
Oh shit.
Fight like a man, Vol.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Oh, sick bird!
Ah, Salat.
Find those bombs!
He's still pointing at it.
It's like...
So dramatic.
With the glasses.
What he has to see!
He doesn't have 2020 vision.
He's blind.
Oh, where's...
Oh.
It's like...
I'm so obsessed with this.
ready for some more snake oh shit wait there's more i told
you phase two oh oh my god what the fuck whoop oh whoop i
want some more oh whoop okay cqc where's my cqc cqc Yeah!
Get down!
There you go.
Nice.
All right.
I could do this all day.
You might want to kill her.
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Well, I did see it.
Yeah, I saw that lightning coming right at me.
Just be ready.
Just...
Ooh.
All right.
What?
Yeah!
Oh, it hit me.
They'll hit me.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Dodge.
See you, Sam.
Get dodged.
Now I can't, not can.
Now I can.
Thank you, Sam.
I couldn't!
Oh, no, no, no!
I got him, I got him, I got him!
Oh, you can, you can!
I got him, I got him!
Wait, where's my shotgun?
Oh, there it is.
There you go.
All right.
Oh, my God.
One minute.
Oh, God.
Women, not even close.
Not even close.
One minute remains.
Stop wasting time.
Come on.
Oh, God.
CQC.
Oh, shit.
Oh, geez.
Oh, I want to like...
CQC, CQ.
Oh, geez.
No!
CQC, CQC!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Get his butt.
There we go.
There you go, got it, got it, you got it.
Nice, you're not even close.
Oh, yeah.
Yay!
All right, I can get out in one minute.
It should be fine.
Easy.
Yeah, that's pretty easy.
Can't be that bad.
Nah.
Oh, shit.
Ew.
Oh, man.
That's like goopy blood.
Even Snake is going through.
I mean, Snake's been going through.
Yeah, it means I don't think he has had time to recover at
all.
I think there's like maybe at least 50 bullets in him.
Minimum, yeah.
Yeah, minimum.
This guy is like him going through a metal detector would be
insane.
Beep, beep, beep.
He'll never get an MRI ever.
Yeah.
They why did they had a full 20 minutes.
Yeah, you couldn't have got out wouldn't it and also that's
just that Yeah, he's like whatever it's like I hope my
boyfriend gets out.
Yeah, oh he got out.
Yeah
He's just like until we meet again
Hop in
That is the longest two minutes step on it I know.
It wasn't even two minutes.
It was less than a minute.
Yeah, it was a minute and 30 seconds.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Five.
Johnny.
Johnny, too.
I mean, if they hadn't gotten got by the explosion, they
would have got got by you.
Literally, that's what you would have done to him.
Set him on five.
That's true.
the boss let me go the river oh my god that crooked
sometimes it's hard to see how large it is oh the crocodile
hat's covering the booms the sacrifices we make holy he's
jumping down
I was hoping I wouldn't have to tell you.
Oh, yeah, the boss is at the lake.
I don't want you to fight her.
Why?
It's my final mission.
I've come to realize that there's a special relationship
between...
I gotta do this, though.
Something I can't understand.
Something that goes beyond a man and a woman.
I envy you.
really i do but i guess i just can't understand it she asked
me to tell you something yeah what is it i've never seen
someone with such clear eyes what
i've never met someone with such clear eyes you mean i yeah
she's talking about the boss Oh, that's floating, dude.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Shagohan.
Oh, you're so cute.
Oh, my God.
Not yet, Snake.
There is no escape.
we failed yeah i was gonna say to not light up the fuel what
the fuck was the point
yeah c3 did jack shit oh no yippee have fun wait what you
get unlimited ammo here by the way so just shoot away um
with what i would choose a different Yeah, I was gonna say
with what?
Okay, give me a sec.
I need to change guns real quick.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me grab this and then this.
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just RPG everything.
Okay.
I knew it!
There you go.
Watch out!
Oh shit!
Oh my god, it takes fucking forever to reload!
Oh yeah, that's kind of how that goes.
I miss!
How could you miss?
I don't fucking know!
Look at that little tiny dent in me.
Oh my head!
Turn around, yeah.
Alright, there you go.
Did I hurt myself?
I hurt myself today.
Oh my god, oh my god.
god okay oh my god oh bro okay this this is not ideal come
on isn't this usually how you play fps this is not i'm
trying oh my okay okay all right we're sending this one up
there yeah there we go no this is just easier all right all
right Okay, that Did that hit it?
That hit?
Did that Did that hit it?
Did that What the split slow down your fucking Oh my god Oh
my god, the tank Keep taking out my god, okay Okay, that hit
though, that hit, right?
Yeah, but it's like not doing anything What?
How do I do any damage?
Aim for his arm
Aim for the tread Yeah I don't know What?
I don't know Oh my god oh my god That's it Oh okay that is
it That is
Oh it's still going by the way There's still more Oh yeah
fuck these guys
I don't think Volgan cares about you Oh then go Eva Just go
Just live The bridge I thought you rigged it with I did
we'll lure him onto the bridge then blow him up long with it
good plan the bridge is on the other side of the runway
we'll have to cut through the middle of the base are you
ready step on it if he catches up here we go all right there
we go that's fine okay whoa hey okay he's he's jealous those
were those were warning shots yeah yeah no he's just saw me
with another woman he's like I thought we like what are you
doing yeah yeah I thought we meant something
what the fuck is he just he put a fucking extent oh my god
stabilizer he actually put a stabilizer that's crazy
look at him go
you're not taking him away from it he's mine
stock on the revolver.
That's crazy.
Yeah, but the stock stabilizes.
That's what the stock does.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Oh.
Oh, I'm going to start shooting my gun.
Ooh.
Wait, that's me.
Why did he hit me?
He's still trying to get you.
complicated really okay yeah it's a little hot and cold
right look at this oh my god he's protecting
him he's returning the favor
oh keep shooting start shooting okay okay okay okay okay i
got my where oh there they are oh okay it doesn't matter oh
Alright, goodbye everyone.
Does it really matter?
Oh my god, bro.
Okay, don't fuck this gun, actually.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
I mean, you do have to get rid of them so that she can keep
going.
Okay, all right, let me... I realized that these were not
the right guns.
Alright.
What the...
Okay.
Yeah, watch out for that game.
Yep.
There we go.
Goodbye.
Oh, I saw Kiro-tan!
Yeah, you should use the revolver.
Yeah, I should have... No, not that one.
Not that one.
You should use the revolver.
Okay, the fucking sensitivity on this is crazy though, I
will say.
Skill issue.
Alright, there we go.
Keep it up.
so cute
I don't think I hit a single person when I play above you oh
shit oh shit above you she says at least literally pulling
the trigger yeah I'm like yeah thanks for that warning okay
there's like no reason for me to shoot these guys like
Ashley if I'm just gonna ride past you yeah they still chase
you down the runway but yeah it's kind of I don't know I hit
a couple?
Nice.
Oh, yeah, I did use tranks, didn't I?
Non-lethal run.
Yay!
Oh, Shaggoha's so cute.
He's just like, clawing.
How would you rate this robot?
Yeah.
I think you should have given him legs.
Wanks.
I gotta pee again.
I'll be right back.
All right.
Oh shit He doesn't matter you're in the way get out I can
only go one way Damn it Why the fuck are they shooting what?
Aren't they far the same team?
Why would he even do that?
Every bullet is hundred thousand.
dollars oh
no it's the four three and four miles the
three mile wet run all
right give me a sec let me oh god I'm reloading I'm
reloading all right there you go
how the fuck is he still alive oh it's so cinematic I should
not even be aiming i should look sick oh my god this
actually looks sick when i'm not aiming what the fuck is the
point are you all dead yeah they are oh not him never mind
all right it's over oh never mind there you go
Here, get out!
I'm trying to watch my movie!
Alright, nice.
Okay, we made it.
Okay.
I got you fucking...
Okay, that...
I don't have to aim here.
I have to aim again.
Oh, shit!
Oh, Ocelot's back.
I've got a surprise for you.
You won't be getting away this time.
a missile it's the acceleration the three-mile ride oh shit
you went maximum maximum overdrive
okay you could have accelerated that like 10 minutes ago oh
god back to aiming
okay you should be off your fucking bike how much fucking oh
shit Oh, shit.
Okay, I don't even think I had to get them out.
I'm just going to do it for me.
Hello, guys.
Oh, no, it does nothing.
I don't even know if that does anything.
Oh, goodbye.
Okay, I did 0.1 damage.
All right.
Um.
Okay.
oh shit what do I do the arms oh god oh god the reload all
right that that did guys guys did I did I do it did it work
Dude, come here.
Just fork it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How's it coming?
Nice.
There's two shot missiles on me and I tanked all missiles.
Because I was like, I was like, I'm going to parry with my
RPG.
And that did not work.
That's a good plan, though.
Actually, I'm going to change my habit.
All right.
Oh We're almost there.
We've only got one chance.
Yeah, one chance when the shagohara is on the bridge shoot
The oh shit.
Okay.
I've got this You've got this I can shoot it.
Yeah, one shot to end the war You really have like two
shots.
Okay, two shots.
Do I have to worry about the guys behind me?
No, okay.
I will fully believe you Let's go.
All right.
One shot.
Oh, never mind.
Not yet.
Almost.
Yeah.
I'd say I feel like you have like one more hour to go.
From the game.
What?
Yeah.
Is that too much?
No, no.
It's just, this really does feel end game, but okay.
give me like one hour of cutscenes right like um well that's
part of the hour oh okay
but when the fuck do i have more cutscenes than gameplay
there's like four i'd say like four more big events that you
have to do and then you're good oh oh r1 yeah yeah yeah oh
all right now just wait until he's on the bridge she's gonna
backseat you yeah what do you mean i see i literally see it
like i i that's right here now no she's so bad
okay she's kind of the worst
it worked okay i thought he was just literally a drive
across the bridge honestly oh i forgot one big thing that
you're gonna have to do okay i think you have more than an
hour okay that's all right that's all right that means you
have to stay for another hour too i'm here i didn't forget
about the woods or rather i remembered one i remembered the
chase scene in the woods not the other part of it oh my god
i just realized it's because of the boss isn't it it's
because of mommy um there's more it's over but you can
definitely do it tonight okay i can do this you can do this
oh now that i know there's still an hour left i know he's
still alive
holy fuck
yeah this is the theme zone yeah
Don't pretend like you know.
I know this by heart.
What are you talking about?
I'm part of the team.
All right.
Let's take care of the shaggle hood.
You got it.
I was getting tired of running away anyway.
All right.
It's rocket launcher time.
Oh, yeah.
R1.
I'm R1ing?
Oh.
I could have spanked.
oh my god oh my god whoa whoa she got the guy she actually
got the guy guys it was me she kissed it was me she leaned
into you know she was kissing me um she was talking about me
she was talking she kissed me no no it was me all right oh
wait that's not the right gun that's not the right gun yeah
yeah all right you got this it's not that bad it's not that
bad in this game Oh shit, okay.
Yeah, you have to, like, you do have to parry those guys.
Okay, fuck, okay.
This is okay, okay.
Alright.
This is a little rough for me.
Alright, there you go.
Yeah, easy, easy.
Please, reload!
He did.
Aim for the wheels.
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah.
There we go.
Easy.
Nice, easy.
one yep easy yeah and then what and then what uh there's
like the back seat well she's not moving so it's kind of
hard but see where it's sparking on the back yeah okay yeah
you're late for that all right easy okay okay um you gotta
help even just sometimes eva really is not great yeah eva is
really me over right oh my god
Okay.
Nice, easy.
Nice, nice.
Okay, Eva, I really need you to work with me here.
Like, I really need you to work with me.
Like, it's just, please.
Okay, and then can you...
And she doesn't move.
It's okay, okay, okay, I hit it.
I hit it.
I got the angle.
There you go.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Alright, Eva, I need you to work with me here.
I need you to She's gonna get you the angle Maybe Alright
Eva Eva please Please Okay Okay She's doing it Please Eva Oh
it's fine It's fine It's fine Oh you got Yeah Yeah this is
like a normal experience Eva Oh my god Please I don't know
why she just drives into it Alright there you go But now
you're done Okay There you go You're done She like changes.
She like moves without warning.
There we go.
Nice.
Wearing him down.
Very slowly.
Very slow.
Slow and steady.
But not too slow, Eva.
Not too slow, Eva.
Eva.
Alright.
There we go.
That tried.
Alright.
Nice.
Now get him in the booty.
And the booty.
Did it hit?
That didn't.
No, it did not hit.
How did that not hit?
hit oh there we go there you go there you go there you go do
that again yeah no that's what i've been trying to do all
right that was a good shot though come on oh yeah okay no oh
fuck
all right there you go yeah all right all right what that
hit that was a hit that was 100 i hit
All right, Eva, Eva, Eva, Eva.
Okay, okay.
Wait, front works.
Okay.
Front works.
I'm done.
Are you done?
Are you- Oh!
Oh!
Oh, God, what a terrible angle.
Oh my God.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's fine, it's fine.
I don't think that hit I'm leading it as best as I can I
can't move Oh my god Snake please Snake please reload Oh
Okay That's 5
Alright there we go There we go Oh my Oh please Eva That's
what I've been trying to do The entire time Is this version
easier?
Yeah though okay okay there you go nice one more hit one
more hit yeah yeah we are definitely doing that yeah yeah we
don't you love stolen valor did
we beat him no we do it phase two there's no way oh my god
there's no way it's even more actually it's better you don't
have to rely on eva oh that's true that's true it's just me
and him oh my god the cqc again are we doing a rematch no
you'll see it's great oh what the fuck he becomes
ratatouille what the What?
Wait, the wires are, like, in his arms.
Wait, he's ratatouilleing it.
He's ratatouille.
He's actually ratatouilleing him.
I can't believe ratatouille stole this from Melgear Solid.
I know, right?
It's actually pretty messed up.
Get off.
What?
I'm going to lure it back here.
Okay, she doesn't do that.
Oh.
Just, uh...
Just...
Just run.
Just, every man for himself.
Well, how do I outrun a tank?
Come on, you blockhead.
Ooh, yeah.
Yeah, you got this.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I don't think I can outrun a tank.
well she still distracts him kind of but at the same time
you just gotta gotta run
yeah all right just do the same thing all right okay that's
okay this is a lot actually i don't like this you also don't
have unlimited uh rockets anymore oh that's not Cool.
Do I shoot him?
Okay.
That's fine.
Yeah.
Keep it up.
Are you fucking okay?
That is fucking crazy.
How is he still shooting?
Okay.
There we go.
Yeah.
That's so much for like the, I'll distract him, you know.
Why is this happening?
Yeah.
What did I do to the Yiddish?
Oh, gosh.
It's fine.
Are you fucking...
Okay, wait, wait, it worked.
Okay.
Yeah, Evo, why aren't you distracting him?
Why are you not distracting him?
I did 20 years to reload my fucking missiles!
Okay.
Did you say what's the matter?
She's so rude.
Yeah, why aren't you doing the thing that I want you to do?
You should, like, reload.
before like i mean there you go nice there you go hey see
it's not so bad just can't beat all right there you go i got
this i got the pattern down oh oh it didn't work what like
this there we go i swear to god i swear to god what okay
it's it takes so okay the only issue of it is that by the
time I reload,
like...
Uh...
Oh my god, why am I...
I'm just gonna shoot the other one.
And see if that works.
Alright, there we go.
There we go, yeah.
Yay!
Nice.
Yeah, Eva just drives in circles and like, between you three
i feel like her not baiting him is easier for me i know like
when he's just sat and you're staring at me there's a quick
reload man there's a quick reload that's not in this game oh
okay nice okay and i didn't like the unequipped quip no they
don't you can't do that in this game who's afraid of a
little thunder
huh oh he has maximum power now oh never mind he overloaded
it's like those saw you put too many sockets oh wait who oh
shit oh it's so messed up oh my god yeah he plugged too many
things in the socket all the bullets on him like oh it's
crazy Yeah.
Oh, that's fucking rough.
Woo!
Woohoo!
Happy New Year!
That's the end.
Feliz Navida.
It's finally over.
Oh, I thought so too.
Why did you say Feliz Navida?
It's Happy New Year!
This
seems very...
Look, oh, this is the ghost.
This is San Lee.
Oh, no, you're getting chased again.
By who?
I killed the leader.
No, it's time to go.
The escape craft is just up ahead.
Oh, my God.
Let's get going.
Also, guys, I saw you saying that the reload does work.
It definitely didn't work when I played.
So unless they patched it, then I don't know.
know oh my oh my oh my god okay fuck this
there we go not bad not bad is there anything else we're
five you got this oh you're so far away yeah yeah it's five
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Whoa, whoa!
Wait, the RPG actually worked!
Yeah, they're like kind of crazy.
Woo!
Yeah!
Shoot them down!
Alright, I'm gonna fucking reload my RPG.
How are there still this many people?
No, I'm just like, bro.
Over here.
Like, I would just leave.
I am.
I like...
Yeah, with the AK!
Alright.
I love this.
Oh, reloading, reloading, reloading!
Oh, shit!
It's fine.
Yeah, it's fine.
They're not really...
Yeah.
Yeah, they're not really that much of a risk to be fair.
Yeah, who's paying for these motorcycles?
I know.
It's an ambush.
It's an ambush?
It's been an ambush.
Yes, it's all been an ambush.
Wait, this is just what?
Oh, I do have to kill him Why she stops here.
I'm just like you could have just killed him.
Oh my god.
Do you want me to shoot them or not Eva?
Just so my okay.
Okay.
She does not.
She is so obnoxious and she gets worse.
I'm sorry.
Okay, all right I like literally do not have to shoot
anything.
I hear that.
Okay
I don't know.
Am I supposed to be watching or playing?
She's testing your skills.
I can't tell.
I can't tell if I'm supposed to be watching or playing at
this point.
Like, at this point, I can literally just not do anything.
Also, you're going to have to watch out for your front, too,
because you have to shoot the logs.
What?
Yeah, there's, like, logs in the road or something.
These seeds are so chaotic.
It's always the same.
It's always bad.
Like...
Oh my god.
Why is it not shooting?
Okay, there it is.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
No, she can't jump in.
Not this time.
Like, I can't shoot him because he's...
Oh my...
Okay.
I actually have to, like, do like, a scroll.
Oh my god, why isn't it shooting?
The fucking slowest turn of my life.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a log.
You gotta get the log.
Shoot the log.
Where is it?
Did I shot it?
That right there.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I got it, I got it.
For some reason, she can't jump over it like she's done in
the past.
But.
Oh my god, there you go.
It's just too much pressure, you know It's fine.
You're not taking like oh there we go.
We're good.
Yeah, yeah
Yeah, I swear to God I'm about to shoot another dog.
Oh my god Weeks up my weeks up.
Oh, where is he?
Where is he?
Oh my god, where the fucking?
Is he still chasing us?
Oh, okay.
I think it's five there's also behind you oh my god the
driver the goddamn getaway driver there you go take them out
take them out is there another log no log there's just more
people oh yeah there is get the driver okay if he thank you
driver if he oh that's a lot of people that's okay
right yeah that's where we're that's where we're shooting oh
my god oh my god that's funny that's it i'm i'm pointing out
the keyboard i was like i can fight with controller it's
fine i can do controller oh no this is this is horrible no
no this is actually no this is horrible no this is so bad
never mind this is this feels much better this it's like
almost over too so uh There we go.
Yeah, I didn't know that.
That felt much better.
Here comes her jump.
Oh, now you can jump?
Oh, oh, that is...
Okay, that's a big jump.
Beat it.
What'd you think of that?
She's, like, so quiet.
Because she's all the way over there.
I can't hear her talking.
Zau's yours, Ewest.
Nice.
Thanks.
Looks like they finally gave up.
Don't start celebrating.
We're leaking fuel.
Oh, shit.
Just get a band-aid.
Just hold your hand on top.
Get your finger and plug it up.
Literally just plug it up with your finger.
Oh, my God, Eva.
Oh, Eva.
No.
No, she's going to be depressed.
It's literally her life.
She's going to be depressed.
Oh, Snake, you were supposed to shoot the logs.
Stokey, why didn't you shoot the log?
I was looking at the fuel!
Oh?
Is she okay?
She seems fine.
Does he have a hole in his ass?
Does he?
Sure did look like him.
Yeah, see...
Oh.
It looks alright.
Is this...
It's alright.
Oh.
Oh, she's such a...
She's such a pussy.
Oh, I have like 20 bullets in my body.
She's not built for this.
Snake is a brick wall.
Oh.
Let's go Okay, we could literally like take that out and
then like get to go get a lighter and Stitch that up I don't
know about that Surely it didn't hit any sensitive organs It
looked like it passed right through See you act this week
Now he's saying exactly what he said Like bro, it's such a
pussy I can do that in front of snake.
Oh my god.
I need you.
Say that one more time.
Oh.
I can't fly the wig by myself.
That's the only reason.
He's like, I don't have a flying license.
He's so stupid.
exactly like the dumbest man and i
oh shit wait she's actually removing it i said that's a joke
oh she's kind of hardcore yeah bro you just cut the branch i
know right i was like it's worse that now it's a gaping
wound i think you're bleeding out she's holding one side but
what about the other it's okay i have lots of suture kits Oh
boy.
Oh, I have my first aid menu.
Okay, tutorial time.
The game is just getting started.
Oh my god, I finally beat the tutorial.
Yeah.
Snake, can you hear me?
Yeah, I'm medic.
Thank God.
Eva's been seriously hurt.
Yeah, I took her to like...
Luckily, I think her organs are all intact.
See, I told you.
It went through the organs.
Around the organs, not through.
Yeah.
I was trying to run around the organs.
I understand.
So you've got to calm down.
Right.
Okay.
Now let's open up the survival viewer and treat the injury.
Do you have supplies with you?
I'm running kind of short.
Then by switching the survival viewer over to Eva, you can
treat her wounds too.
Now get to work.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure you know this already.
But if you don't have enough supplies for the both of you,
your wounds come first.
Do you get my meaning, Snake?
You've still got a mission to complete.
She's like, kill her if you have to.
But she hot.
Alright.
Kira.
Wait, wait.
Me first.
That's fine.
I have so much.
Okay, have fun with this next part.
Alright, and then...
Bleeding.
Infect.
Boom.
See it.
Easy.
Afflicted area.
Now you see.
That's split.
Bandage.
There you go.
Alright, Eva.
Can I actually leave her to die?
Uh, I don't think so.
Oh, so.
Like, I just don't heal her.
Alright.
Wound bleeding.
Uh.
Yeah, there's some fun little secrets if you, like, look at
her medical history.
oh i didn't check her medical history i just went straight
to curing her because i am a gentleman yeah i was so focused
can you walk dies
oh she's looking at my lips my eyes are up here she wants
you so bad oh here Take my gun.
Are you still check?
Time to geek out.
All right, all right, snake.
Give us 10 minutes of this.
That's like first date material.
That's what you know he's into you.
Oh, yeah.
Tells you about his gun.
And not the one in the pants.
Ooh.
Wait, I can see you see it.
Snake, are you all right?
I've been better.
What about Eva?
I healed her up.
She can manage.
Snake, you'll take the lead and break through the enemy's
line of defense.
Eva will ordinarily be following behind you.
If you lie on your belly, she'll lie down as well.
If you slip and fall off a cliff, she'll follow right
behind.
You can call out to Eva by pressing the action button.
God, is this...
Is this an escort mission?
Yep, baby.
Have fun.
Oh, it's bad.
It's several areas, too.
But it's just this, and then one more thing, and then you're
done.
What's the survivor?
Wait, what's the...
And then a lot of cutscenes, but yeah.
Wait, how do I look at her?
Oh, medical history.
Oh, medical history, yeah, triangle.
back pain.
She got the tummy ache.
Oh, she got tummy ache.
Oh, I get that.
Broken meal.
Okay, frost, but gunshot wound, bronchitis, breast
enhancement, sleep paralysis, cavity.
Okay.
What is that?
What?
You can see your food history too.
It's just kind of funny.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Stomach ache, broken nail, cord, a blow, sustain.
Hey, chill.
Bless you.
Thank you.
Electrical burn.
Those are all vulgan.
All right.
Melon tofu.
Damn, she eating good.
I like to look at her food history and then go to my food
history and just compare the two.
Seafood, fried rice.
Grilled picking dogs.
Russian floss, mango, gelato.
Gorgonzola cream, fettuccine.
I hate her.
I mean, I had a pretty good time until vulture, vulture,
vulture, vulture.
It's like, it was all right.
It's like, rat ration, tree, frog.
It's a vulture, vulture, vulture, vulture, vulture.
Hey, those were apparently pretty good.
Yeah, apparently I killed.
She's out here having cheese omelets.
Yeah, apparently I killed so many vultures that they showed
up in the fucking river.
But like, but like when, but no other animals showed up
except.
Yeah,
I think I killed a little bit too many vultures there.
Okay, wait, do I have?
All right, I don't need luck.
I'll just kill everything on my path.
She's so obnoxious, though, I'll let you know.
Oh, God, all right.
It's fine.
You can knock her out and carry her, but you can't go into
other areas without her being conscious.
All right.
She's not following you, by the way.
Like turn around?
Oh my god.
I cured you.
She still has a stab.
I don't understand.
All right, back to my naked woodland.
In case you missed it, Doki, Eva actually ate all the ramen
and calorie mates from your old food inventory when you lost
it earlier.
Oh, that's what she ate.
is it this way which one am i supposed to go okay it's this
way all right a bandit stopped my impalement i'm fine
oh my god i'm just gonna kill all of them fuck this yeah i
think it just might be easier it's kind of horrible this
whole section i'm just gonna go full murder mode fuck this
there's no river
look at all these johnny jesus fucking christ how many
people did they break
oh my god yeah i know just leave no one's paying you like
the guy the boss is dead who the fuck is paying you guys she
doesn't know about the second river there is no second don't
fuck with me right now.
I'll put a list of the answer just in case.
But I'm going all in.
Don't forget to call Eva or she won't follow you.
Oh my god, get over here, Eva.
What?
They're behind you.
Remember, they came in from behind you and she didn't follow
you.
So they saw her.
Is she okay?
And now they're killing her.
Oh my god.
there we go let's go eva come on eva come on eva oh my god i
gotta this is the second river this okay give me a sec okay
uh bullet lodge
this bandaid oh my god disinfected you did this oh you
didn't get a bullet lodged into you but they shot you first
okay eva i hope i'm going the right way to call or you are.
Come here.
Uh-oh.
The alert went back up.
They're here.
Where?
Oh my!
Eva, please stand up.
Eva, Eva, please.
Why are you limping?
There was another guy.
No, it's fine.
Oh.
Oh my god, where is he?
saw me that's that's good there we go get over here eva get
over here where is she
yeah isn't it great there you go eva you get get over here i
think there was another guy oh no oh my god eva okay that's
why she they were like if you don't have enough oh my eva
eva eva get up get up get up eva eva don't shoot that guy
what do you mean by emma oh your suppressors but it's fine i
guess i don't think i don't think it matters anymore i don't
even you get a cure eva i need her to get close to me for me
to cure eva please please for it oh there's there's a yeah
yeah this is the first area oh my god oh my god i'm so angry
i'll take care of it she says there we go she's so cute all
right okay eva come on eva eva eva eva eva she like sits
down and then gets off like a grandma's okay we can we can
do this we i love a woman's bones okay i wish i had bones
all right everything is fine we can do this everything is
fine okay come on come on eva eva eva please am i even going
okay there you go eva it's okay here you go
oh my god i'm a tie i'm hungry oh my god eva get over here
eva at least ash oh my please at least Ashley oh my god oh
they missed her Eva I swear do you know what you're doing I
swear to God what's wrong Eva eat eat this tastes like crap
it's oh my god you're Russian she's not she's not but she's
like being a spy for her own place Did she say that?
Oh.
Kiel.
One more guy.
Like, how does it feel to betray your own country?
So I thought she was, like, Russian.
Oh, my God.
It's right here.
Oh, you're going the wrong way, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you gotta climb the little...
Yeah, that thing right there.
Wait, what?
Yeah, yeah.
And the ledge?
no no turn around turn to the left to the left that ledge
right there i see i see yeah yeah how am i getting a call
they're telling you you need eva eva should be able to climb
it if you help her keep her close to you okay what
do you oh my god okay okay i was just like what do you mean
just just a bird It's just a little baby.
I literally killed like 30 men for her in this one area
alone.
Look what you see.
Keep baby.
Let's do it again!
Oh my god, Eva.
Okay, the guys here, they're just kind of like chill.
Oh, oh, oh, wow.
Oh, it's fine.
Do you know what I'm here to?
Oh, you're out of bullets.
I fucking...
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no.
She's dying, you guys.
I didn't think this is true.
Hey, you guys.
This guy, like, yeah, right?
Oh, where'd he go?
Wait, what the fuck?
Where is he?
He's, like, in the bushes, yeah.
Okay.
I think he's dead.
Oh, there's a... Yeah.
Okay, they keep coming in.
this.
Where's my...
RPG!
Okay, maybe not that.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I thought that was...
Come on, Ducky.
I thought this was where we were going.
You gotta call her.
Oh, there she goes.
She's hobbling away.
She's coming.
Slowly but surely.
She's coming over.
Alright, let's see.
Alright, I'm going left.
Come on.
Come on, Eva.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Come on, Eva.
Come on, come on, boy.
Come on, girl.
Come on, come on, girl.
Come on, Eva.
We're almost there, girl.
You can get all the guys in here, too.
You can just find them and...
Yeah.
I like seeing their little exclamation points and then you
can know where they're at.
He's definitely here.
Okay.
no more exclamation point how the fuck am i gonna get the
rest of them
all right let's get get the fuck it is he is she here where
is she oh i think she's on the other side where oh my get
over there she is eva eva please eva please she's hungry
please understand eva eva please oh my god eva you didn't
see oh my god i'm literally at like one meter away and she's
like i'm worried her vision is going out she's bleeding out
wait where's snake i didn't see you okay all right you eat
this okay you eat this oh i'm running out of food yeah you
might want to get some food yeah yeah there's no why okay
there is mushrooms there is you can see them like rustling
in the yeah and there's some all right i'll grab this
mushroom yeah all right okay time to go straight down i
don't care if he should get shot can she make that i don't
think she can no
i think you might have to like give me a sec i go get her
Let me go get her real quick.
Keto time.
Alright, come over here.
Come over here.
You could, like, knock her out and then drag her off the
cliff.
Alright, come on.
Come over here.
Alright, wait, wait, wait.
It's fine.
Come over here.
What do you...
She's so...
She tries to be insane.
Oh, you're not race baiting me right now.
All right, there you go.
And then you go down.
There you go.
Okay, she can go down.
She can go down.
Oh, my.
Oh.
Did you see him?
Okay.
That was the last guy.
Yep.
All right.
Okay, it's there.
All right, I'm going to...
Okay, I need food.
Do you have food?
Yeah.
Oh, man.
You'll have food in the fight, but, you know.
Okay, that's good.
That was a sick-ass headshot I did.
Alright, get over here.
Come on, Eva.
Yeah, that was good.
Eva!
Eva?
Wait, where is she?
You could farm food here, for real.
Eva.
Eva, get over here.
I'm eating the last Russian ration.
Fuck you, Eva.
I'm eating the last Russian.
Eva, please.
Eva, I have several more.
I have several more places to go.
No.
You're so close.
All right.
Do you have any Russian ration?
Oh, my God.
It's just bullets.
It's like bullets I don't even need.
Oh, my God.
Just don't even.
Just ignore her.
Just go.
Yeah.
It's okay.
There's no way she can die from starvation.
No.
She'll get a nice caviar meal later.
but I'm so hungry oh my god Eva please so how please you can
please you can last like ten more minutes if you're so
hungry eat the man I just killed if you're that hungry oh
come on snake
yeah I'm suddenly she can run isn't that I know that's crazy
that's actually crazy that like she pretended to fucking be
dying for like 10 minutes 15 minutes like oh and you're not
hungry no more oh okay it's the boss isn't it I'll go get
the wig ready to take off right I'll leave you two alone but
come back in one piece okay
One piece One piece Promise me
Oh my god And she's just running Prancing around to the
plane Oh yeah like Yeah the fucking wound that you got
earlier Oh shit What the fuck
Whoa What the fuck was that the plane planes life's end
isn't it beautiful they're so beautiful when life ends it
gives off a final lingering aroma light is but a farewell
gift from the darkness to those on their way to die i've
been waiting snake for a long time
your growth and the finality of today boss why are you doing
this why to make the world one again oh the world used to be
whole but with the end of the second world war the
philosophers began to fight amongst themselves and the world
was torn apart the Cobras all comrades who trained and
fought alongside me were torn apart as well.
The foothills of politics and a march of time can turn
friends into enemies just as easily as the wind changes.
Ridiculous, isn't it?
Yesterday's ally becomes today's opposition.
You good?
Yeah.
I'm alright.
As America and Russia were fighting together.
Now, consider whether America and Russia still be enemies in
the 21st century oh yeah
boss oh boss and we soldiers are so helpful
i didn't raise you and shape you into the man you are today
just so we could face each other in battle a soldier's
skills aren't meant to be used to hurt friends So then what
is an enemy?
Is there such a thing as an absolute timeless enemy?
There is no such thing, and never has been.
And the reason is that our enemies are human beings like us.
They can only be our enemies in relative terms.
The world must be made whole again.
The philosophers must be reunited.
I will devote my skills to that purpose.
We are the world.
And with the Colonel's money, we are the pain.
Yeah, just don't worry.
Michael Jackson will unite us all.
It's Macross.
Oh, but I still have a family.
It was November 1st, 1951.
Oh, my God.
I was in the Nevada desert.
I'm I'm going to use the bathroom wash the name Nevada is
derived from Spanish covered in snow white is snow and snow
is exactly what I saw in that Nevada desert it froze my
blood white oh it's the first testing of the nuclear bomb
atomic test subject weren't you on bikini at all bikini
that's part of the reason i was drawn to you you and i are
alike we're both slowly being eaten away by the karma of
others we'll never have the chance to die peacefully of old
age we have no tomorrow but we can still have hope for the
future oh snake right there like MGS3 like original render
of him from space three years earlier the Soviet Union had
succeeded in launching Sputnik oh Sputnik made satellite in
history I know I know that this came as a real history real
real history Kojima made history it had into its own manned
spaceflight project the mercury program
seem poised to send their first man into space.
America was still experimenting with chimpanzees and
rockets.
Monkey.
The government wanted human data.
So they secretly decided to send a human being into space.
Who could that be?
I was the one they chose.
Oh my god.
Her?
It's not Neal Armstrong?
And whoever they sent up would inevitably be exposed to
heavy radiation that's why they chose me after all i'd
already been irradiated once of course you won't find any of
this oh that's why she can't have children i could see the
planet as it appeared from space that's when it finally came
space exploration is nothing but another game in the power
struggle between the u.s and the USSR politics economics the
arms race
I'm sure you can see that, but the Earth itself has no
boundaries, no East, no West, no Cold War.
And the irony of it is, the United States and the Soviet
Union are spending billions on their space programs and the
missile race, only to arrive at the same conclusion.
In the 21st century, everyone will be able to see that we
are all just inhabitants of a little celestial body called
earth a world without communism or capitalism that is the
world i wanted to see but reality continued to betray me
in 1961 i was sent to cuba to baye de cochinos it was part
of a cia sponsored invasion under the guise of taking cuban
exiles back to their country but the u.s government betrayed
them our weak need president held back their air support
defenseless the exiles were annihilated by the cuban army oh
all i could do was watch in silence no i was set up by the
very country i sacrificed so much by the very government i
dedicated my life to defending from the surface world and i
went underground then two years ago i faced the sorrow my
old comrade in battle oh oh i love it it was my friend and
but one of us had to die oh oh i was left with no choice oh
that was the skeleton i saw yeah it was him there is no
enmity between us one must live and one must die that was
the mission the mission the one who is the mission were the
philosophers Stanley early in the 20th century the true
holders of power in the United States the Republic of China
and the newly formed Soviet Union gathered together in a
secret meeting that would later be known as the Wiseman's
Committee the secret marked the beginning of the
philosophers but the last of the original members Thanos
Thanos Thanos oh my god and the wise men's committee
degenerate Thanos snap Thanos the philosophers of today have
no sense oh my god who else is Thanos oh snap Thanos they
have become war itself until there's no one left that's how
they operate the sacrifices of war cause a shift in the
times this shift leads to renewed conflict and in turn
triggers the next war like a nuclear chain reaction each
conflict sparks countless others forming an endless spiral
that will continue on for eternity do you understand what
I'm saying snake by consuming me and you the philosophers
intend to keep that cycle going did you see the little baby
yeah over there the right side oh her dad was oh you see i
am the last remaining child of the philosophers it's like so
sad but after he revealed the truth my father was killed by
that same shapeless
My father isn't the only thing the philosophers have taken
from me.
If all those philosophers are God, then how could they take
more?
I took part in the landing at Normandy.
We'd been given a top-secret mission to locate and destroy
enemy V-2 rocket installations.
I was pregnant at the time.
The sorrow was the father.
on the field of battle a beautiful baby boy oh my god that
is mummy but my child was snatched away from me by the
philosophers it should me or i should not wait
look at this scar oh i was once a mother worst c-section
ever yeah i was gonna say like why did it they have to cut
up to the boob
super botched job and yet sometimes at night i can still
feel the pain creeping up inside me like did the doctors not
know where the ovaries were like the ovaries to get the
babies out the baby's not stored in the ovaries yeah see i'm
like the doctor i was like where is the ovary
the baby is stored in the boob yeah the baby is stored in
the boob snake oh oh commence the operation i raised you i
loved you i've given you weapons taught you techniques
endowed you with knowledge there is nothing more for me to
give you that's where the big is the big boss her kid is
that a big boss me or osilat one must die and one must live
no victory no defeat the survivor will carry on the fight it
is our destiny the one who survives will inherit the title
of boss oh the one who inherits the
What the fuck was that scoff?
No, that was me sniffing, sorry.
Oh, yeah, okay, okay, sure.
You guys will come and bomb the hell out of this place.
That's 10 minutes.
If you can get me in less than 10 minutes, you'll be able to
escape in time.
Oh, shit.
This is the greatest 10 minutes of our lives, Jack.
Alright.
Do I need a CQC here?
Finish your mission.
I will say that you are time.
but this fight is best enjoyed slowly
oh oh good luck wait
oh what the fuck she's seen you seen me yeah and she took
apart your weapon by the way my weapon okay wait I got this
watch this Oh shit Watch this What Her bullets are stopping
Excuse me Yeah CQC It's actually kind of important Oh Oh
okay Honestly it's really hard It's like pretty The timing
Oh you're covered in flowers the timing i think you can get
the timing but it's it's pretty difficult i can't get it all
right the cqc yeah but i think you could you're a gamer okay
all right let's see
wait how what she's gonna take apart your weapon no is that
all you've got no i'd be a sec let me stand up oh i see it
like i see like when she when she rushes you like there's
also a way to do it like there's a all right oh she's
running into the okay the mother of all special forces is
she's running into the tree
oh here she comes to cqcu oh shit you might want to oh shit
oh okay oh Another gun gone.
Another gun gone.
Oh my god.
Oh she's fucking me up man.
She's fucking me up man.
She's too good.
She's.
Oh wait.
Seek you see her.
I'm where I am.
I see you see.
What?
How did that?
What the fuck is going?
What?
Why can't I see?
You gotta keep doing it.
gotta keep doing it no like like what it like there's no
prompts for it like you have to do it like in the cutscene
it's very strange I didn't even see it it doesn't it doesn't
appear it's a timing thing how do I know the timing you just
that's That's the issue.
I...
I pressed it.
It's hard.
I'm...
Do I press it or hold it?
Like, is it a press or a hold?
That's the thing.
It's...
You can get it.
Oh, you're getting hungry.
I'm getting hungry right now.
It's okay.
We'll keep doing it until it works, right?
Come on.
You can just feel it.
Just feel when you press it.
Um.
Oh.
I don't think I felt it.
It's okay.
She took apart, like, all your weapons.
No, no.
I still had, like, 20 more.
I still...
Just don't press until the slowdown.
Oh.
It's the same thing here, too, yeah.
I...
I like how you're trying to figure it out.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll figure this out.
Wait, what?
You rolled into her.
Wait, I could do that?
She's just taking a nice look now.
Wait.
Wait, oh, shit.
Oh, shit.
Where is she?
Oh.
Oh, there she goes.
I like the sniper in this fight, but...
Is the sniper good for this fight?
Well, yeah, if you're hidden, but also...
Oh, no!
My snob!
I just equipped my sniper!
No!
My...
Bro, I'm not disinfecting that.
Okay.
I will never figure out CQC.
I will never figure...
She does not know the basics at all.
She doesn't know the basics.
Shooter!
That didn't do much at all.
Yeah, it did not.
I'm dead.
try when he grunts is what someone said when he runs what
does that even mean
did i do it no god damn it i just want to cqc
okay um she's
not getting closer right there's five it's okay
there we go give like a couple minutes come on donkey I mean
by that time it will be a couple minutes I'll just have to
shoot her so she doesn't get close to me it's fine it's as
close quarters as we're getting this is the close quarters
yeah this is CQC why is she only staying over there This is
my CKC.
What?
Choke about.
Yeah.
Hello?
She's still peeking.
Oh?
Oh, she can't get me.
I'm reloading.
Oh?
Oh, I'll shoot your arm.
Why is she only staying over there?
Oh, my God!
CQC.
Oh, no.
This is bad.
It's okay.
She'll stop shooting.
I see, though, the sniper for this is like...
There we go.
That's 1 HP, right?
Hmm.
Maybe.
Is that 1 HP or should I...
Shoot her again?
No, just... No, no, no.
Just chill for a bit.
Yeah?
Yeah.
She's not gonna get close to me, right?
No.
No?
Just taking everything.
The last fight.
Okay, now...
Now...
Come on, just let her get close a little.
She's getting...
She's getting a little too close right now.
Do the CQ so you can have those.
I don't... I don't know.
Just chill.
You got time.
You got lots of time.
All right.
Hey.
Hey, boss.
Oh, there she comes.
She doesn't know where you are.
Hey.
Hey, boss.
be cool she has no idea is that it's like where is he it
just it's just me and a crocodile yeah we'll hide and seek
yeah oh oh you should have moved she's a Oh, okay, goodbye.
What's wrong with her AI?
Yeah, this is fine.
Whoa, look at the pedals.
They're so beautiful.
How much more time?
I feel like it's taking forever.
I feel like something bugged out because like Is it Is it
not time yet?
Does she know?
Does she know I'm being time?
I know Oh Oh What was that?
What was that?
What happened to me?
She didn't heal herself Yeah Is it because I didn't heal
myself?
Oh I should heal myself myself i guess feels a lot longer
when you're not in the driver's seat is that the case all
right all right well all right it's a beautiful day we're
just we're just yeah we're just vibing we're just vibing she
still doesn't know she doesn't know oh no where am i maybe
move a little bit yeah don't let your butt be seen
Yeah.
Ooh.
Oh, five more minutes.
Oh.
Oh, the music's starting.
Do I kill her now?
You don't want to kill her when the end of the song happens?
Oh, you just want to listen to Snake Heater.
You just...
Isn't it so epic to fight her when the instrumental's going?
well you're not really fighting her are you she's kind of
goofy actually she's just okay you can
kill her I can see you see her watch this oh no okay go I'm
here
Do you go through the rain?
Is that it?
Just slow down!
Oh, you had it!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
She's...
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, just press it or hold it?
Oh, here she comes.
Oh!
Get her!
There we go.
Don't do that.
Yeah, that was the best way to end it.
Not with the tea bagging.
I see QC there.
Oh, it's the last first leg of C.
yeah
hide it in the croc oh my god you should have taken it off
what
do you mean it's so immersive the fucking crocodile shadow
or should i say snake you're a wonderful man kill me I'm yum
yum yum yum
Oh There's only room for one boss and one snake
You gotta do it.
Oh
I tried to do it more than once but it didn't let me
gonna be like boom oh it's all red oh my god what the fuck
was in that blood she's powerful she's the boss Eva's like
waiting for us and all she hears is like a speaker blaring
like music that's just like gotta wait for the song to
finish No, the horse!
No, her horse!
No,
her horse!
What the
fuck?
Oh, the snake is gone.
It becomes a snake.
Oh.
Yay, you beat the game!
Okay, there's a lot of cutscene left, so I...
Oh, okay, not yet.
We still have more to go.
But no more gameplay.
Oh, okay, it's just cutscene, all right.
Yeah.
No, she beat the game, you guys.
This is where you would call time in a speed run.
Time.
Yeah.
And the SGDQD.
WCB.
Oh, I'm sorry.
There's one more gameplay.
You guys are right.
Fine.
Oh, my God.
There's one more.
I'm sorry, my mommy.
Mommy's dead.
Are you okay?
Like, as if he didn't have to kill her.
Oh.
Oh, it's white again.
I
told you you could trust me I'm so immersive show immersive
oh shit did you forget someone oh my god it's an oscillot
bro bro he's such a jealous X man yeah he's so jealous
through yeah we're not done yet you picked her instead of me
oh my god oh
there's this truly is heated rivalry here comes the 1000
pound man
looking for those
What you gonna do now?
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
They are so close to kissing.
This is foreplay.
Yeah, absolutely.
Oh
shit!
Fly the plane and they're making out.
Try to remember some of the basics of CQC.
That stance.
Oh, CQC time.
That's all he knows.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, so that was not smart.
Ocelot's too fat.
Somebody's Duffy has got to go.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no, reversal him.
What the fuck?
Is that physically possible?
They're just dancing at this point.
I'm like, is that even humanly possible to do in the fight?
The fucking flip.
He tried to get him in the eye.
Yeah, I'm watching WWE right now.
oh oh he tapped out he had him pinned and just let him go
yeah
now this is wrestling oh no not the gun though she's like
please somebody help me i'll get over it oh the gun that oh
oh my
oh yes It's so good.
One more shot.
Oh, the magic bullet.
One last showdown.
Yeah, all right.
The crock at me.
Every time.
Get to me.
All right, pay attention.
Okay.
Oh.
Snake's got his own moves.
He learned it just for him.
That's the left one.
All right.
R1.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Oh, man.
Okay, aww.
I love this game, man.
Crock Cat is such a...
Oh, shit.
I didn't do it.
The crock difficulty.
Not that name.
Your real name.
You're not a snake.
And I'm not an Ocelot.
Don't say that.
You are an Ocelot.
My name is Adamska.
Adamska!
I don't, Scott.
Drawing Metal Gear.
Drawing Metal Gear, yeah.
But I won't forget!
Sorry.
Come on!
All right, make the right choice.
You know, Oh, oh, now I took off the croc.
Now I took it off.
Now you can't have it.
Nothing left.
All right.
You can pick either one now.
Go left.
Okay, let's see.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, it's a showdown now.
Let's see.
You hard time.
A good old duel.
Yeah, poor Eva.
Do it.
Oh, it was me!
Yay!
Okay, I was not aiming there.
I'll just say that.
It's a blank.
What?
So there was no choice.
Choices don't matter!
This guy!
Just a prank, bro.
That was fun.
Why?
Alright.
See ya, but bro.
Now he's gonna do the dumbest thing I've ever seen him do.
Oh my god.
Also, I- You're not gonna- No, man, whatever it lives.
He's just like, nice.
He had his wrestling and he's fine now.
He's satisfied.
He's actually so stupid.
He's in the middle of the lake, you guys.
Bro, he's literally rolling on water, bro.
He's running on water.
Jesus.
The second coming of Christ.
She's just been going in circles trying to keep the plane
up.
Yay!
Okay, now you're done.
So funny.
It's like such a good scene.
He was like, now that I have my personal time with my
boyfriend, I leave now.
Yeah.
We made it.
Yeah, we sure did.
Aww.
That's actually crazy that Ocelot brought the plane weight
down.
I know.
He is the thousand pound man.
Yeah.
Also, what are we gonna do with that horse?
Like, did we just left the horse there?
Yeah, we just leave the horse.
That's a domestic- Ocelot's ego is like 500 pounds away.
No, his gun alone is like 100 pounds.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
There's no way out.
What are we gonna do?
We've come too far to let them stop us now.
Those things have got to be armed.
It's no use.
There's no way we can outmaneuver them.
Unless?
They're gonna shoot us down.
We were so close.
They were so close.
Weapons systems on.
Locked on targets.
Wait.
They sound American.
You were great, Eva.
Everybody has sounded American.
We did it!
Oh, I think they realized they're not getting paid.
I didn't realize now.
They're like, oh, the commander's dead.
Oh, probably, yeah.
Yeah.
They were like, they told me to shut down.
Look!
Just a prank.
Oh, nice.
Yay!
They just want a kiss.
Oh, my God.
Oh, he's blocked.
Always blocked.
Again.
Oh.
The MiG's disengaged.
Most likely under orders from Khrushchev.
Is this his way of helping us?
Who knows maybe he didn't want things to get messier than
they already are or maybe he just wanted us to owe him one
The important thing is you made it out alive.
I did it Yippee yay It should be smooth sailing all the way
to Alaska croc block someone out to Galina base to meet you
to meet me the DCI and the president himself are waiting at
Langley Don't keep them waiting.
Yeah, no President wants to see us
Alaska hole.
I'm gonna get a medal of honor.
There's still so much cutscene.
I'm sorry.
I'm really sorry.
Oh good.
All right, Kojumbo.
What do you want to show me?
What is this beautiful storytelling?
Am I gonna see?
Oh, okay.
What am I?
Like, is it Christmas now?
Like, what?
of we just we just took over this cabin and something
stay with me i wish he still had the croc head on left
america behind me
you can be american like where are we
right now yeah we're in like the nicest abandoned cabin over
is that part of someone someone's uh airbnb yeah is it an
order or is it an invitation
oh i missed the crockhead me too it's much more intense i
don't take orders from anyone now Oh shit!
Whoa!
On the carpet!
Oh my god!
He finally hit puberty.
I can't watch.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, Snake!
You're fond of!
Is she an R1?
R1, R1, R1?
R1?
She was looking at me.
Oh, cock blocks again.
Nah.
I'm just crying.
Aslak, don't knock.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's the government paid for that.
That's fine.
She's like, Shake, there's a bushel coming here!
Oh my god!
That was not the smartest thing that Eva did.
Okay, sexy time is over.
Damn, oh my god, look at all those veins.
Look at all those wounds!
Oh my god.
Good morning.
Snake.
A snake.
What's wrong with this tummy?
What you do to him?
What the fuck is wrong?
What?
Okay, what did you do to him?
It's like a giant ass hickey on the stomach.
Oh my god.
But she was just like vacuuming the stomach.
Okay, here's important Lord.
dump fruit of knowledge forgive me snake ah she took the
philosophy goodbye one night stand oh
snake is always getting played by someone man oh man snake
she took his kidney it looks like it looks like she took his
kidneys are it
jesus christ he's a heavy sleeper i wasn't sent by cruise
ship i'm not a kgb spy and i know i'm an agent of the
people's republic of china the third party
Never would have expected it.
Oh my god.
She's Chinese?
You know that video where it was like, he's actually
Chinese.
You know this?
Wait, you did not heard of that video before?
Oh, there were philosophers in China.
Yeah.
So I infiltrated his base as a K-2.
The two NSA code breakers who defected in 1960 Were actually
both men The real Adam never showed up at the meeting place
Saving me the trouble of having to eliminate him I sneaked
in by pretending I was Eva That's why she didn't know The
Yorolala Rala Ba La la la la lilo
I knew it I was like you know she didn't know The Chinese
government had its eye in the legacy too But she was hot
we've just trusted her And also the nuclear missile launched
data from the shagohad Oh my god well she got too many
things The Soviet Union stopped supplying us with nuclear
weapons technology Since then, China's Leon Don easing.
Yeah, Toki, you don't know the password either.
Yeah, but I'm not part of the government.
We'll create a deterrent force to rival those of the U.S.
and Soviet Union.
That color is not the color that was on the back of that
thing.
Thanks to your help.
I, too, am one of the philosophers.
I'm an agent of the philosophers, a graduate of one of their
charm schools.
Charm schools?
I was raised in a joint U.S.-Soviet China.
He's like a honeypot.
Charm school.
Back then, they were collecting children from all over the
world.
As a result, I'm indistinguishable from a native-born
American.
So it didn't surprise me when you and Vulgan couldn't tell
the difference.
But she knew right from the beginning.
She knew because before the war, she was at one of the
philosopher's schools too as an instructor.
The boss.
My boss was the only one I couldn't fool.
Yep.
She was the only one who knew I was a fake.
She told me everything.
Why did she open her heart to me like that?
Wait!
At the time, I couldn't understand it.
Mommy?
But now, I think I do.
Oh, Snake.
She wanted you to know the truth.
She chose me to tell you.
That's why she saved my life.
I've lied to you so many times, but not this time.
My orders from the government were to obtain the legacy.
Holy shit, the fuck did you sit through all that?
Drugged his drink.
Oh.
I thought he was just tired.
He could be too.
Maybe he's some sleep.
Yeah, yeah.
All everyone does just lie to him.
And not because you saved my life.
But because I made a promise to the boss.
And I intend to keep it.
But you know, the saving your life thing is pretty important
too.
Yeah, and you know.
He did, you know, wash you limp for like two force levels.
Poor Snake.
Always getting deceived.
He got lied to by...
She's always self-destructs.
Yeah.
Like the good old spy movies.
That's this whole game.
Everybody's a spy.
Snake.
Should have picked us a lot.
She didn't betray the United States.
No.
Far from it.
She was a hero who died for her country.
It's the famous scene.
I know this Metal Gear reference.
I would hold
R1 here.
Holy shit, that is fortunes.
Oh my god, it is.
She's so cute.
You are above even the boss.
I hereby award you.
Big boss!
I got it!
At what cost?
You are a true patriot.
La la lo lo lo lo.
Oh, look to the left.
What the?
What is he...
What is he doing there?
I'm just imagining like is his boyfriend like he's just
imagining his boyfriend right it's like I wish he was here
to watch me get this award
oh this guy sucks
He actually lives for it free.
Someone like him to handle our top secret sneaking missions
for us.
A man who combines the qualities of a soldier and an agent.
The boss's defection was a ruse set up by the U.S.
government.
so they could get their hands on the philosopher's legacy
and the boss knows the story of the show see she was a
double agent and destroy the shagohad at the same time only
a legendary hero like the boss could have earned vulgan's
trust finding out where the philosopher's legacy was hidden
was to be her greatest mission everything was going
according to plan and then but then one could have
predicted.
Colonel Volgan fired an American-made nuclear warhead at
Sokolov's research facility.
Krutzev demanded by the U.S.
government to provide proof that it wasn't involved.
They couldn't just abort the operation to steal the legacy.
So the operation itself was greatly expanded and revised.
I don't think the crew got the memo.
I literally think they just told her our name.
The others were just like, yes, man.
And that one of their own would have to do the job.
The end.
The public couldn't be allowed to find out about it.
Not ever.
This they concluded would be the best way to keep the whole
thing under wraps.
The boss wouldn't be allowed to come back home alive.
And she wouldn't be allowed to kill herself.
Her life would be ended by her most beloved disciple.
It was all scripted.
That was the way the government wanted it.
That was the mission she was given.
And she had no choice but to carry it out.
Because she loved her country.
Oh!
Out of duty, she turned her back on her own comrades.
A lesser woman would have been crushed by such a burden.
The taint of disgrace will follow her to her grave.
The future generations will revile her.
The world never changes.
In America as a despicable traitor with no sense of honor.
And in Russia as a monster who unleashed a nuclear
catastrophe.
She will go down in official history as a war criminal.
And no one will ever understand her.
That was her final mission.
And like a true soldier, she saw it through to the end.
But I think she wanted you, of all people, to know the
truth.
She wanted to live on in your memory.
Not as a soldier, but as a woman.
She was forbidden to tell you herself.
That's why she told me.
Snake, history will never know what she did.
No one will ever learn the truth.
Her story, her debriefing, will endure only in your heart.
everything she did she did for her country she sacrificed
her life and her honor for her native land she was a real
hero she was a true patriot oh seven oh seven oh seven oh
it's shaky blurry vision
history history diva disappears oh the spans fox oh and then
they became the patriots establishes foxhound oh
let's What the fuck is the sun...
Oh, is that where we get Solid Snake?
And Liquid Snake?
DMCA, by the way.
Oh, whatever.
Yeah, that's fine.
So where we get Solid Snake?
You would know that from...
Oh, man.
And Metal Gear Solid 1, but that's okay.
means like that's why we get all the different variations of
snake like solid liquid and then metal yeah yeah and what
and met you know it's like and gas you know like the you
know solid metal liquid gas vapor you know yeah all of the
all different elements of snake yeah yeah there is a ending
cut or like a post credits thing too yeah it's short it's
short but thank you for Yaka Supa next see thank you for
picking this game it was fun you think it was it was I now I
understand the Metal Gear solid references now I some of
them yeah I understand some of the some of the Metal Gear
references like I get it I get it yeah motion actors wait
there were motion I thought it was hand drafted no yeah
motion actors for these oh oh yeah because it's a new ritual
as well oh
Kojima Kojima Kojima oh okay i thought it would be like
mostly Kojima Yoji Sinkawa is the other guy that's like
critical here he's the artist he like does that did all the
yeah what do you think of the story or like just like like
It was, yeah.
It feels like Kojima definitely had a lot of fun writing
this.
He had a blast.
Yeah.
So good.
Now you gotta play the other games.
It was truly cinema.
Yes.
really was I get it I think definitely I think from from all
the streams my favorite part was when we were like R1 while
he was flipping the guns and then the giant crocodile was
there and I was like I don't think we're gonna make it I
It's so good.
You guys, I can't make Doki play the rest of the games, but
if Doki has another Donothod.
That's why you'd be at charity auctions?
Yeah, at a charity auction.
That's what it was, yeah.
That's my Donothodod.
I get it, though.
Like, the games are so good.
but like there it's a long it's a long undertaking so yeah
oh i've got something in my throat i need to be alone while
i suffer
There's a hole inside my bones And you need to stay afloat
For it's a summer A sun Better wait to fall They'll tell you
where to go but they won't know
if you ever feel like oh i'm not gonna play the other games
but you want to know what happens just let me know and i'll
tell you oh yeah okay okay wait do in the other games you
find out like who was the kid no no so it's more so like
implying so who was it who was it was it sorry naked snake
awesome Bosses kid?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's Ocelot.
It's Ocelot?
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
She wouldn't hit him like, like, like, she's her mom, you
know?
Yeah, your mom, yeah.
Yeah.
I was, like, debating, it was either big boss or, like,
snake or, or Ocelot.
It was one or two.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
No, like, snake, uh, naked snake is not, like, her actual
child.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's kind of like, oh, I raised you.
because you're like mentor, you know.
Yeah, it was like, you are like a son to me.
Yeah, there is like a codec in this game that kind of
implies it.
So, but yeah, also it does look like the boss, too.
He looks like the boss and the sorrow.
Wait, what was that co-op Metal Gear game that was really
good?
Was the Peace Walker, the really good one that everyone
loves?
Um, it's really good, I agree.
Yeah, yeah, that's what it is.
No, you know what I'm talking about.
You're adding a really good one.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
There is, there is, like, a fox hunt in this game that's
online.
So you can play with people, too.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
That's the, Peace Walker's the zombie one, right?
No, that survived.
Oh, why don't we play that?
Okay, let's play that.
I still haven't played it, so let's play it.
Isn't that the really good?
Wait, you're a Metal Gear...
You're the Metal Gear Vtuber, you haven't played Survive.
I know, I'm... Actually, I haven't played another game
either.
Wait, which one was it?
And that was a really good game I was talking about, guys.
Survive.
Oh!
Like, I knew you had a tone in your voice and I knew you
were bullshitting, but...
Okay, that was a really good game.
Here's the extra scene.
Yes, Grozny Grad and the Grannon research facility have both
been wiped out without a trace.
The horse!
I understand, sir, but they were necessary sacrifices.
Yes, the CIA has taken care of the boss themselves.
I believe the White House will be satisfied.
Khrushchev is finished.
the time is finally arrived who is he talking to yes the
American president is relying on us to keep a lid on the
whole affair we've got him by the balls oh shit it should
make a valuable Trump card in future negotiations medical
return for doomsday yes of course I'll keep the KGB informed
yes it's me the boss is accomplished her mission all he knew
the philosopher's legacy is now safely with us he's also
okay he's america okay america's hands okay i was gonna say
he's also chinese yes the philosophers can finally be
revived the film we handed the chinese was a fake oh peking
must be in an uproar right about now
anyone actually not a double agent oh no ocelot is a triple
agent please understand
yes the weapon has been reduced to ashes
that's right grazney grad has been obliterated by the davy
crocket we brought in as well that blast earlier yeah that
was like right before the boss's battle speaking of which
i've obtained something from granon that you might find
interesting it's a revolutionary 10-d chest right now oh my
god from granon handy someday like i should have snake snake
is like literally like the yes we have the the fucking pond
for that we have john yeah he's totally a pond yeah yeah i
know in my first name basis now his name is i know i don't
think they'll be making a fuss he's been thinking of john
this is their time they haven't even talked again he's been
like john john john metal gear they have no idea that i've
been triple crossing them jesus christ i will continue my
activities as a contact for the new government oh my god are
we gonna find out he's actually quadruple crossing and later
that no one knew that i was adam he was adam the whole time
adamska i mean of course My name is a damn sky.
I'm always at the CIA's disposal.
Mr. Director.
Da-da-da!
Yay!
Oh, my God.
Oh, your title is Crocodile.
What's that even mean?
You've got the croc hat on the whole side.
Oh, I killed a lot of people.
Oh, wait, how many?
Holy!
I...
Whoa!
Oh, wow.
Whoa, oh...
Um...
Nice.
I got the Patriot.
You get the Patriot.
Oh, I got a Takedo.
Yeah, vanilla camo, yeah, yeah.
A lot of camos you get.
Mommy grenade.
reward white tuxedo got oh that's that's what guys have yeah
that was a game
you did it we did it
whoa oh my hey we did beat the game we beat the game it was
possible and we did do it you pushed through you did good we
did it we both did it we achieved something today black
screen oh okay i was gonna say it yeah what were we waiting
for title screen yeah or the song yeah it's time oh yeah
it's really late for you right now yeah it's almost 3 a.m oh
shit yeah i think i'm gonna go to sleep thanks for Thanks
for accompanying me for this playthrough.
I think it definitely enhanced my experience of it,
especially when you were like my like fun fact guy for Metal
Gear.
At this point, let me tell you, it's like watching the Lord
of the Rings with somebody.
He was like, did you know that Gandalf was actually a film
separately from the hospital?
Did you know that he actually broke his hand in this scene?
His screams of pain were real.
Did you know the giant eagles were real?
He actually found them in New Zealand.
He broke his foot.
It was tough.
It's so...
They actually threw a man in a volcano.
Did you know that?
Nobody was harmed in the making of this film except for
everybody except for that one guy they threw in the volcano
all the people that were killed on screen we're actually
killed now you understand all of these cut scenes yeah i was
like oh that was in the intro this one the simpsons
reference
Snake it up.
In my time.
Oh, that part too.
Oh, the shot go hard.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's dead.
It's the way.
I'm flying to you.
I'm still.
In a dream.
Snake it up.
Oh, that's cool.
it changed to reflect it but ggs meant thank you for
accompanying oh my god the horse is still there what the
fuck is he gonna do i don't know i feel like someone should
take him like someone should take him back home don't worry
he goes to he goes to south america oh a word okay i i hope
he has a good trip yeah somehow he gets there yeah um Thank
you all for watching, guys.
I had a blast finally understanding the Metal Gear
references, or some of them.
Yeah.
And what do you want to, do you have any final words,
Schmidt?
Nope.
I love Metal Gear.
All right, guys.
As always, everybody, say hi, David.
Are you going to talk to your chat or no?
No, I'm ready to clock up now.
Okay.
tomorrow too for a tournament yeah um but as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
and get that blood flow you stay up for a minute and head to
bed because you deserve it thank you everyone for the
support and all the super chats and all the subscriptions
and everything guys thank you thank you thank you it was
such a blast streaming this for all of you guys and it was a
great experience i'm gonna men and i are gonna head off now
i haven't eaten dinner So I'm gonna grab food and also head
to bed soon because I tomorrow stream for me is like at I
think like 11 a.m.
I don't remember my own schedule.
Oh, I think it's 11 a.m.
I think about I'll see you guys tomorrow morning everybody.
Yeah, bye guys.
Bye.